good morning ladies and gentlemen if
okay
Let Me Wait Till Jen Force back in the
good
Jen the question has been asked if we
okay the time is 9 33 and I'm going to
convene this working meeting of the
commission on worldwide combined
reporting for unitary business under the
business profits tax
um
I want to thank everybody for being
flexible there was quite a bit of
juggling Logistics to line this full day
up but I'm extremely pleased and want to
give some praise and appreciation to Gen
4 who I think has been a terrific
communicator and everybody who's here as
we have scheduled a half hour for each
group and I'm confident that that will
allow for a presentation as you've
planned and then a good robust round of
questioning and we'll take the questions
one at a time around the circle we do
have two other members who I'm hoping
will join us and but we're going to
proceed this is being live streamed so
it'll be recorded and available for
anyone who wants to go back and view any
part of it on YouTube on the New
Hampshire house Channel
also a number of our guests are coming
to us remotely so we have a video hookup
as well and
I think we've got everything dialed in
as far as the technology to go smoothly
because we have a whole array of guests
who maybe don't know who exactly is
sitting up here on the dice I'd like to
just quickly have each of us introduce
himself starting over here with Kim Wong
good morning my name is Keane May Wong
text policy council at the Department of
Revenue Administration I am the designee
for the commissioner of the department
Kevin
I'm Kevin Kennedy I'm a certified public
accountant here in New Hampshire I was
asked to be on this commission by the
I'm Matt Foley also a certified public
accountant and I'm here on behalf of New
I am a representative Tom Schamberg who
has
had all of you come here to spend your
money in New Hampshire this weekend
thank you very much
and I'm representative Walter spilsberry
Sullivan County District 3 representing
Charlestown unity in Newport I go by
Terry and we have two other legislator
Representatives who I'll I hope will be
able to join us and that's
representative Laurie and Senator Murphy
so with the introductions
out of the way
our first panel uh Tom Opel O2
strategies LLC
and Tom is joined by Dan Commons founder
and owner of Dan Collins painting
specialist and a selectman of Canaan and
Peter Garr formerly of the Department of
Revenue Service who tells me his
retirement project is primarily chopping
wood you can see how fitty is
thank you Mr chairman
goes off by itself
um thank you for the opportunity to
testify before you today in support of
New Hampshire adopting worldwide
combined reporting and ending the
water's edge provision
and as I say in the legislature I'd like
to associate myself with the Chairman's
comments about Jennifer four she's been
fabulous so thank you to Jennifer
um I am Thomas Opel president of o2
strategies a strategic consulting firm
based in Canaan New Hampshire
and a small business person myself I
represent today the Coalition for a
prosperous America
which is a non-profit organization
representing the interests of 4.1
million households across the political
spectrum and economic sectors working
together for a new and positive U.S
trade policy that delivers prosperity
and security to America its citizens
Farms factories and working people
and as the chairman noted with me today
are Dan Collins an independent
contractor from the Upper Valley of New
Hampshire and Pete Garr who worked on
business tax issues for the Department
of Revenue Administration in the 1980s
and 1990s each of whom will speak after
me
in the 1999 caterpillar decision
the New Hampshire Supreme Court spotted
the basic issue facing this commission
today when it wrote and I quote
we point out that the water's edge
method was adopted for the benefit of
foreign businesses
and the very next sentence in that
decision makes it clear that ending
Waters Edge and adopting worldwide
combined reporting is hardly
unprecedented
the Court's decision noted that and
again I quote
prior to 1986 New Hampshire utilized
worldwide combined reporting
so the fundamental question this
commission should ask itself
is why New Hampshire businesses
contractors store owners craft breweries
or any other domestic company
should be treated differently when it
comes to their business tax liability
compared to foreign Enterprises
obviously we welcome all business to the
state whether domestic or foreign
but why should New Hampshire's business
tax structure privilege foreign
companies
domestic companies employ more than 9
out of ten Granite Staters and that's
using Global business alliance's own
figures
so why should those 9 out of 10
employees and the owners of those
companies be forced to operate at an
economic disadvantage
and now the New Hampshire has moved to a
single sales factor in determining
business tax liability it is very likely
that the competitive disadvantage for
domestic businesses for those mom and
pop stores could become worse
multinationals as you know have the
capacity the global operations and the
financial incentives to use accounting
techniques paper transactions and other
tactics all perfectly legal to shift
profits to lower tax jurisdictions
overseas
Water's Edge Provisions obscure the full
picture of their activities in New
Hampshire from dra because companies are
not required to account for their
operations outside the U.S beyond the
water's edge
as I said these techniques are legal but
they're anti-competitive and create a
two-tier tax system
the disadvantages homegrown businesses
who act whose activities are limited to
the New Hampshire and the U.S
domestic businesses do not share the
accounting capacity or overseas
resources as a result
these companies pay more than their fair
share to support state operations funded
by business taxes
or the state is shortchanged of Revenue
in a taxation system a Level Playing
Field would provide
or finally and this is the most likely
outcome we get a little each a little
bit of each bad outcome
and frankly that's already happening a
joint January 2019 study by the American
sustainable Business Council U.S perg
and the institute on Taxation and
economic policy approximated the cost of
multinational multinational profit
shifting as potentially accounting for
177 million dollars in Lost Revenue
annually just to the state of New
Hampshire
this is revenue that could be used to
relieve taxpayers either through direct
tax cuts or by increasing Aid to cities
and towns to relieve property taxes or
to provide other services
such as support for public schools
with Worldwide reporting companies must
do for their entire Enterprise without
regard to borders
this is what they do now for operations
in every state in the U.S
and obviously any well-run business is
doing this in every jurisdiction across
the globe although they're not sharing
this data with New Hampshire
or at least they don't have to
without worldwide combined reporting new
hampshire-based businesses and the
overwhelming number of granted state
workers they employ operate at a
significant competitive disadvantage
and those are the companies who employ
the vast majority of workers workers and
companies who are committed to their
communities and are critical
contributors to the economic health and
quality of life in our state
Dan Collins who's run his own business
for nearly 30 years can speak to that
impact
and Pete Garr can explain how adopting
worldwide combined reporting and ending
Waters Edge rather than being some novel
or even radical scheme will simply
return New Hampshire businesses to the
structure that existed prior to 1986 and
so I'll give
good morning everyone
thank you for having me as Thomas said
uh my name is Dan Collins
I am a 50 year old self-employed
residential painting contractor based in
the Upper Valley here in New Hampshire
I sit before you today as a
representative of small business owners
I've been a house painter full time
since I was in my mid-teens
by the age of 18.
I was promoted to job site Foreman
and that's when I realized that my
career was going to be as a Tradesman
at 24 I started working for myself
I spent the last 26 years building a
small business here in the granite state
in that time
I've had upwards of a hundred people
worked with me and beside me
I have built a home
I've raised a family
I've sent my daughter to college
and I've taught my son a trade
and for all of those 26 years I've
always paid my taxes
as a locally based small business
I've never been afforded the opportunity
to shift my profits elsewhere to reduce
my tax bill
that puts me in an economic disadvantage
with foreign companies and
multinationals that can take advantage
in our local municipality
I'm fortunate enough to sit on the
select board
I serve on the planning board
a preservation committee as well as
several subcommittees such as updating
our master plan for economic growth
and exploring options for a community
center
I have also as a select board
representative
had the opportunity to serve on our
budget committee
as a public official
I have both the honor and the burden
of setting a local tax rate
I feel it is my responsibility as an
elected official
to work as hard as I can to keep all
residents of our community on the same
playing field
we have a Level Playing Field in regard
to property taxes
I would suggest we need a Level Playing
Field with regard to business tax as
well
with the potential Revenue loss of 177
million dollars per year in the state of
New Hampshire
I'm sure there are many municipalities
in the granite state that would benefit
from revenue that is now being shifted
elsewhere
I would ask this commission to report
favorably to the legislature on ending
Waters Edge
and adopting worldwide combined
reporting as the right step to create
that Level Playing Field
I thank you for your consideration this
morning
and I appreciate the opportunity to sit
good morning
my name is Peter Garr
I submitted the only Amicus brief and
the caterpillar case
my Amicus was over 30 pages
my testimony today is six now six and a
half pages long
I trust I will be afforded the time to
read it to the commission
I was the business profits tax auditor
with the Department of Revenue from 1980
to 1997.
during that time I traveled around the
country to the headquarters of
corporations that had operations in New
Hampshire
most of the corporations that I visited
were multiform with a parent Corporation
and any number of subsidiaries operating
when I started in 1980 the audits were
conducted on separate accounting
separate entity tax returns
for example if the corporation that had
operations in New Hampshire had a
subsidiary
I audited only that subsidiary as if it
was a standalone Corporation with no
connections to related subsidiaries
or the parent Corporation
in these audits few adjustments were
made to the tax base
most of the audit adjustments concerned
the apportionment formula the percent of
sales payroll and real property in New
Hampshire to total sales payroll and
real property
then the law changed in 1981 that
allowed the department or corporations
to employ the unitary combined method
of course corporations that benefited
while unitary tax returns to pay lesser
amounts of business profits tax
however it was only upon audits that
combined corporations paid more business
profits taxed under the unitary method
it should be noted that the new that New
Hampshire adopted the unitary worldwide
combined method before it had been
tested in a lawsuit
that lawsuit container Corp V California
purpose of the unitary combined method
was to counteract The Profit shifting
that occurs between corporate members of
a group of Corporations controlled by a
parent Corporation
enter company transactions occur at
prices determined determined by internal
corporate accounting departments and
international accounting firms
referred to as transfer pricing
the big four worldwide accounting firms
are based in Britain and tax avoidance
as their specialty
a good example of profit shifting
transfer pricing within the United
States is Home Depot
which formed a subsidiary in the state
of Delaware
it was revealed in an Arizona lawsuit
that the Delaware subsidiary had just
four employees
but reported profits of about 4.7
billion dollars over three years
compared to 3.8 billion over the same
period for Home Depot the parent
Corporation
profit shifting like this was and is a
huge loss for separate accounting
separate energy states
that utilize the arm's length principle
where inner company transactions are
supposed to be the same as between
after New Hampshire adopted the unitary
business principle in 1981
it was the policy of Lloyd Price
the Dre commissioner that we would not
employ unitary combined reporting that
the subsidiary was owned by a foreign
parent
as a result of this policy Barn owned
corporations were allowed to continue to
file
separate accounting separate entity
business profits tax returns
I thought that this policy was wrong
the letterhead of the Department of
Revenue is the old man in the mountains
surrounded by the words equity for all
treating U.S subsidiaries owned by
Foreign parents one way on a separate
entity basis
and U.S subsidiaries owned by U.S
parents another way on a worldwide basis
was and is not equity for all it does
not ring true
in 1994 the U.S Supreme Court and the
Barclays Bank decision found that it was
constitutional for a state to employ the
unitary worldwide method with a foreign
parent
the vote was seven to two in favor of
California
in the companion case where the U.S
parent Colgate Palmolive the vote was
New Hampshire attorney general at that
time Jeffrey Howard joined an amicus
in support of the worldwide method also
filing an amicus and support were United
States Senator Senators Byron dorgan Ted
Stevens Frank murkowski Judd Gregg and
I just realized I missed the page so I
have to back up a little bit I apologize
regarding Home Depot
if Home Depot was a foreign parent and
had similar had a similar subsidiary in
Bermuda or Luxembourg most likely no
profits or diminished profits would be
reported to and taxable by Uncle Sam or
any state
there are a number of documentaries that
explain how multinational corporations
avoid income taxes by shifting profits
to tax Havens
I recommend watching too
the town that took on the tax man a
British production
and the tax-free tour a Dutch production
both are available free on YouTube and
it's best to watch with closed captions
on
I do not know why the business profits
tax law was changed in 1981 but I
suspect it was due to the U.S Supreme
Court's 1980 Mobile Oil V Vermont and
Exxon V Wisconsin decisions
New Hampshire attorney general Tom Rath
joined other states in an amicus brief
that supported both Vermont and
Wisconsin
if you haven't read these decisions I
encourage you to do so
both cases concerned separate entity tax
returns filed by mobile and Exxon
although mobile and Exxon were very
profit profitable for the years in
question
mobile reported zero separate entity
profits for two of the three years and
Exxon reported no separate energy
profits for all four
of the years in question
in both cases the Vermont and Wisconsin
Department of Revenue employ the unitary
business principle which the court
stated was the linchpin of
apportionability
both States won their case against these
oil companies that had made millions
that had made hundreds of billions in
or not Vermont did not adopt
unitary combination
but they did State their reason which
was described in a well and a
well-written statement of intent which
Vermont's separate accounting system is
inadequate to measure the income of a
corporation with non-vermont affiliates
and creates tax disadvantages for
Vermont corporations which compete with
multi-state and multinational
corporations doing business in Vermont
it is the intent of the general assembly
and adopting a unitary combined
reporting system
to put all corporations doing business
in Vermont on an equal income tax
footing
however for some unknown reason Mr
Garrett yes if I can please interrupt
we have your written comments and I see
they are extensive and the time that
it's taking to read them in full is
eating up the time that
um that your panel has so I'm not going
to stop it at exactly 10 o'clock but I
wonder if you can summarize allow us to
read
the comments in detail which we will do
and and that will leave some time for
questions of the panel
excuse me Mr
determine we started at 9 36 with Mr
opal yes that's why I tend to be lenient
on thank you sir but I do think that
reading the entire thing will not serve
you the best
I'll try my best
in 1983 the U.S Supreme Court decided
that Container Corporation case
which which concerned employment of the
unitary business principle across a
group of related corporations
container was a U.S based parent with
both domestic and foreign subsidiaries
this was the first time that the court
approved unitary combined reporting on a
worldwide basis
unfortunately the court did not address
unitary worldwide combined reporting but
the foreign parent
with U.S operations
the New Hampshire attorney general at
that time Gregory Smith joined with
other states in an amicus brief in
support of California and worldwide
combined reporting
foreign corporations foreign business
associations and foreign governments
filed amicus briefs in opposition
foreign objections and a lawsuit
concerning a u.s-based multinational
corporation
I would like to read two short sections
from the New Hampshire AGS Amicus
and the Barclays Bank case
quote to believe that a multinational
corporations
that to believe that multinational
corporations do not maintain an
advantage over independent corporations
operating within a similar business
sphere is to ignore the economic and
political strength of the multinational
Giants
by attempting to treat those businesses
which are in fact unitary as independent
entities separate accounting operates in
a university of pretense
as an Alice in Wonderland it turns
reality into fancy and then pretends it
is the real world
the unitary method of tax accounting is
an integrated consent conceptually Fair
basis of Taxation which seeks to negate
the intense complexities of injured
corporate international tax accounting
embodied in the arm's length method
the arms like method treats each legal
corporate entity as if it were real
while ignoring the identity of the whole
Enterprise
the unitary method identifies the income
of the whole and then apportions that
income according to the proportionate
contribution to the taxing state
after the Supreme Court's 1994 decision
New Hampshire did not repeal the water's
edge method and return to the worldwide
method
after I left the Department of Revenue
in 1997 I felt compelled to file an
amicus brief in caterpillar's lawsuit
against the department
I disagreed with the department and I
disagreed with caterpillar's position
caterpillar argued that royalty and
interest income from as far as
subsidiaries should not be taxable in
New Hampshire
and in other words should not be in
their pre-apportionment tax base and the
alternative caterpillar wanted more
weight in the apportionment factors
either way caterpillar wanted to reduce
the amount that they owed in business
profits tax
I argued that the remedy was the
worldwide combined reporting method that
the U.S Supreme Court said was
unconstitutional was constitutional
I do not know if my Amicus brief paid
any port part in the Court's a unanimous
decision where it stated we point out
that the waters method was adopted for
the benefit of foreign businesses
how else can you interpret or restate
for the benefit of foreign businesses
this is preferential trap tax treatment
not for New Hampshire or Vermont or
California corporations but British
French and German corporations operating
in our state and throughout our country
it would be like a meals and rooms tax
that offered a reduced tax rate or
exemption for visitors from Canada or
Spain
the legislature could pass this in order
to attract more out of country visitors
to New Hampshire but would it be
constitutional
I suspect this is why the waters this
method was not changed back to the
worldwide method after the Court's
Barclays Bank decision
the state wanted to attract foreign
corporations to New Hampshire but at
what expense
the dra did not know what effect going
from worldwide to Water's Edge would
have and business profits tax revenues
the dra does not know what effect going
from Water's Edge back to worldwide
would have on business profits tax
revenues
all we know is that foreign corporations
do not like the worldwide method
and House Bill 121 FN representative
Shambrook said that the 1986 change to
the water's edge method was a mistake
I would go further and say that the
change was and is unconstitutional
the waterset's method violates equal
protection on the 14th Amendment it is
unlawful a bad law that discriminates
in Prior cases the courts have
determined that corporations are persons
and subject to equal protection under
the 14th Amendment
I think of the watersets method as
affirmative action for foreign
corporations to attract them to New
Hampshire
affirmative action is also referred to
as positive discrimination
the watersets method is positive
discrimination if in favor of foreign
corporations
on the other side of that same coin is
negative discrimination for our
homegrown U.S corporations
it is discrimination pure and simple
the U.S Supreme Court ruled earlier that
that affirmative action in college
admissions was no longer valid
what would our founding fathers say
about the state of New Hampshire one of
the original 13 British colonies that
became a member state of the United
States of America after the war against
Britain for Independence against
taxation without representation in
Britain's Parliament
what would Madison or Hamilton say about
an American state that passed a law that
granted preferential track preferential
tax treatment to a foreign corporations
to British French German corporations
avoiding U.S taxes and grants them an
extra advantage in the U.S Marketplace
competing against U.S corporations what
would they say
make known mistake multinational
corporations of all Stripes work to
avoid corporate income taxes they
lobbied to lawyer to lower tax rates to
change the approximate formula in their
favor and above all reduce the tax base
the tax base can be reduced to zero then
it doesn't matter what the tax rate is
or what the apportionment formula is
I'd be willing to bet that there are a
number of foreign-based corporations
that operate New Hampshire that have
never paid any business profits tax
the GAO the federal government's General
accountability office has reported that
over 70 percent of foreign controlled
corporations corporations in the US have
paid zero income taxes
this is why a number of U.S based
multinational corporations have moved to
a foreign country and a tax inversion
multinational corporations go to Great
Lengths to avoid taxes
the business profits tax playing field
is not level
the law has to change to make it level
it has to be changed to move forward
with unitary worldwide combined
reporting for all corporations big and
small U.S or Farm based
or it has to move backwards to the way
it was from 1970 to 1981 where
corporations filed separate accounting
separate entity tax returns and the arms
length principle ruled over the unitary
business principle
big business would like that a full
return to the arms length method if New
Hampshire did that it would be the most
tax-friendly state in the entire country
no general sales tax no income no earned
income tax and the best possible
corporate income tax
the new and improved New Hampshire
advantage
imagine being a clerk at the Vermont
Department of Revenue in the 1970s when
Harry she opens a letter from the mole
Oil Corporation and finds the check made
out to the state of New Hampshire for 25
dollars
the initial reaction of that per person
must be thinking that this is some kind
of joke
Mobile Oil has gas stations in Vermont
and many states and is making hundreds
of billions in corporate profits
and yet here's a check for twenty five
dollars from the oil company to help pay
for Vermont's Public Schools public
roads public health and many other
functions that the Vermont government
provides
clerk enters the check into their system
and sees that Mobile Oil also paid 25
dollars in the previous year at that
time Vermont had a minimum corporate
income tax in 12 of 25 dollars and that
is what Mobile Oil pay to Vermont for
each of the two years
the Vermont Department of Revenue
conducted an audit
plus another one 1970 and they found
that that they should have paid over
seventy six thousand dollars Vermont oil
protested maintained the Vermont tax
returns were correct and filed a lawsuit
that went all the way up to the U.S
Supreme Court
the court records show that Mobile Oil
had millions in Vermont sales and owned
millions in Vermont property
from Mobile Oil lost his case and it was
in that decision where the court stated
the linchpin of apportionability and the
field of state income taxation is the
unitary business principle
it is that principle that overrules the
arm's length principle the arm's length
principle allows multinational
corporations to shift profits from one
state or one country to another
The Waters Edge method retains the
arms-like principle but only for
multinational corporations
the worldwide method is the only way to
overcome the arm's length method
in my caterpillar brief I argued that
the Commerce Clause has the bulldozer
that can and should make the playing
field level and then it is up to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court to decide
whether or not that bulldozer will be
fired up and operated to flatten down
this terribly uneven unlevel and unjust
playing field of Taxation in the global
economy
in hindsight I think I should have also
ordered that the watersets method
violates equal protection under the 14th
Amendment
if the state of New Hampshire does not
return to the worldwide method I can
only hope that a lawsuit will occur to
test the watersets method and find that
it violates equal protection and or the
Commerce Clause
a lawsuit like the 1997 case against the
state's interest in dividends tax
Ernest Smith was a lead plaintiff in a
successful lawsuit against the 70 year
old tax
his Loyals his lawyers argued that the
IND tax was flawed and violated the
Commerce Clause and equal protection
for the Court's decision prior to oil
argument before this court the state
withdrew its Commerce Clause defenses
based upon the U.S Supreme Court's
recent decision and Fulton Court fee
Faulkner Justice suit or delivered the
unanimous unanimous decision of the
Court
the New Hampshire Supreme Court decided
Smith case on just the Commerce Clause
unfortunately it did not rule on the
equal protection argument
finally I would like to quote Adam
Looney at Dartmouth grad and former
deputy assistant secretary for tax
analysis at the United States Treasury
Department
he said that in effect the United States
is paying foreign investors to take over
our own companies with our own tax
dollars
thank you very much gentlemen are there
questions representative Hillary welcome
thank you excuse me for walking in a few
minutes late but
um
for this the uh the lobbyist to answer
for both of you could New Hampshire has
a unique system where the business
profits tax and the business Enterprise
tax work together and offset each other
under Supreme Court rule
I really don't understand how what has
been suggested thus far applies in New
Hampshire
um so regarding Equitable treatment
because every
entity and every business entity is
required to pay the business Enterprise
tax and then that tax is offset against
the profit tax of every entity and under
our rules or under our constitution
each class is taxed the same each class
of entity is taxed the same
even though they can have several
different classes within a one appearing
to be this a similar group
so
where
just
can you
address that for me please
well sir I I'm not the the tax expert
but fundamentally under the current law
in New Hampshire
we do not consider activities beyond the
water's edge Beyond U.S boundaries
in any case for either for the BPT or
the Enterprise tax we simply do not
consider activities so that if you're as
Mr Garr pointed out if you're a
multinational or a foreign owned company
um you have the ability again perfectly
legal but uh putting New Hampshire
businesses at a competitive disadvantage
essentially you have the ability to
shift
uh your profits around
through accounting techniques or or
other tactics
that enable you to reduce your liability
to the state of New Hampshire and the
state of New Hampshire does not have the
ability
to audit activities overseas there's no
reporting
yes go ahead
taking a very large company in New
Hampshire I think it's number one or
what do we care
what we care about Sir is having a Level
Playing Field so that a New Hampshire
business a hardware store for example
um an independent bookstore competing
against Amazon a Craft brewery competing
against Anheuser-Busch
they are paying
their full tax liability they report a
hundred percent of their sales
uh and then pay a hundred percent of
their tax liability based on that sales
a multinational corporation
may or may not be reporting a hundred
percent of their sales activity in New
Hampshire
they certainly have the ability through
accounting techniques
to shift what would rightfully be sales
activity in the state of New Hampshire
to other jurisdictions
and thereby reduce their tax liability
and what that means is
that a New Hampshire company is paying
100 of its tax liability
foreign owned companies or
multinationals are paying less
potentially paying less than 100 percent
that's creating a competitive
disadvantage
it's you know as as Mr Garr pointed out
it's not just unfair it frankly should
good morning thank you for your
testimony uh this is a first question if
if um if I may uh in your testimony you
mentioned this
study this 2019 January 2019 joint study
by the American sustainable Business
Council I'm not sure if if the com
commission received the um has a copy of
that study and I'm and I'm sorry my uh
my personal printer quit on me last
night after I was printing out a bunch
of our the testimony
um I did email a copy of that study to
Jennifer okay this morning so the com
the commission will have access to it
and again I apologize for not having it
in advance that's fine thank you
my my second question is that you you
mentioned just now that uh potentially
the multinational corporations could
potentially shift
their U.S up sorry the New Hampshire
sales activity to outside of New
Hampshire can you just explain further
on
potentially how that mechanism is
Shifting sales that's in New Hampshire
how's that shifted outside of New
Hampshire
um sure uh let me give you an example of
a of a pharmaceutical company
um
uh pharmaceutical companies do a lot of
research in the U.S and they you know
we've all seen the the advert you know
advertisements for Jordans and various
and Sundry other uh you know medicines
for diabetes or or you know rheumatoid
arthritis Etc
um
what has happened uh in the past
um is prescriptions get written in New
Hampshire for one of those medications
and that achieves obviously a certain
sales level
um but what happens is the
pharmaceutical company transfers the
patent
for that medicine
to a subsidiary or
a a another company
in a lower tax jurisdiction the Cayman
Islands Ireland wherever
um
and what happens is that
the pharmaceutical company represents
let's say
a million dollars in sales of a medicine
in New Hampshire
but is required to pay a licensing fee
to the Cayman Islands subsidiary and
that licensing fee significantly reduces
that company's profits
as as reflected based on New Hampshire
sales
um thank you I believe
the the New Hampshire sales most likely
it would still remain as the amount of
gross sales in New Hampshire probably
what's being I think what you're
mentioning is what's being moved outside
is just the shifting of the profits of
the company in general as opposed to the
New Hampshire sales I think New
Hampshire sales will still remain as New
except that it's my understanding and
correct me if I'm wrong it's my
understanding that
a a foreign company multinational
company is under no obligation
uh to provide the same kind of reporting
that U.S based companies have to provide
we have combined reporting within the
U.S so that if if I'm a company that
does business in New Hampshire and the
other 50 states I have to report to dra
what I'm doing not just in New Hampshire
what activities what sales activities I
have in New Hampshire but in the other
49 states I do not have to do that
for activities beyond the water's edge
which enables a company to
use all sorts of accounting techniques
to reduce their liability in the end
it's the tax liability it's not so much
yes Senator Murphy
thanks chairman
I'm holding in my hands that testimony
from the global business Alliance little
prepaid handout if I could sum up what's
in front of me what it says basically is
this would be new this is the only we'd
be the only state that does this every
state that even
allows for it it's only an option
each allows for a Water's Edge Edge
designation
and every state that studied it has said
no
and states don't like to be outliers we
don't like to be first and what I'm
hearing now I'm reading in the testimony
is this would actually be going back to
a prior policy so
what would your answer be to the global
business Alliance
please
New Hampshire is an outlier State we
have no personal earned income
tax we have no general sales tax
the only other state that's comparable I
believe is Alaska
but of course they are rich and
energy resources
so we're already there as an outlier we
have the New Hampshire Advantage we're
supposedly famous for it
so
I've
funding a government has to come from
somewhere
if if we want to be the most business
friendly state in the country
then go back to the way it was between
1970 and 1981 when New Hampshire was a
separate accounting separate entity
state
revenues will drop and whoever wants a
general sales tax in this state whoever
wants a personal income tax or an income
tax they will have their time they'll
have their chance because BBT revenues
are going to drop like a
let me just say we're not advocating
that but um
let me also point out that New Hampshire
was an outlier in 1963 when we were the
first state to adopt a state lottery
um so we've we've done things I I think
the answer is pretty unique in a lot of
different ways and we've done things in
the past I'll also say that
there are a number of other states that
have looked at worldwide combined
reporting and ending the water's edge
and very honestly senator
it's tough to compete with the money
that big multinational corporations
bring to these uh bring to these
campaigns
um the folks the folks who are looking
for equity
folks who are looking for a Level
Playing Field
can't compete financially
with Exxon with Anheuser-Busch with Home
Depot with Amazon
I know in Oregon for example
Nike spent a lot of money to defeat this
proposal which came pretty close to
passing in the Oregon legislature until
um
until Nike weighed in let's just say
that I know the state of Minnesota
just this past year looked just a few
months ago actually came again very very
close to passing this
until there was some significant
activity by the multinationals toward
the end of that legislative session
so again it's you know there I'm not
suggesting anybody acted outside the law
they didn't
um
ERS
hopefully this will be the last question
New Hampshire is adopted a single sales
Factor
uh
without any
study being done beforehand or
comparison study before it was adopted
with the proportionality approach that
we used
what in your opinion
would be the effect of a single sales
Factor now being used have on the
possible revenues for the State of New
Hampshire
I think it's going to be a disaster
where a population of
1.3 million people
so
how big can the sales Factor be
and only the sales Factor
of
items that are sold services that are
sold in New Hampshire
without recognition of payroll and
property
the corporations that have big plants
employ a lot of people
use our roads
you lose the let the rational
relationship between sales payment
property and the activity that's taking
place in this state
you're moving you're moving away from
that relationship going to a pure single
sales factor I think it's a terrible
mistake and I think revenues are going
thank you I have three very brief
clarifying questions
um first it's my understanding that
you're not advocating going back to what
prevailed from 1970 to 81 but rather
what prevailed from 81 to 86. that is
correct correct sir
second is my understanding that the
report that you forwarded this morning
which we'll see is the one that
establishes the claim of 177 million
dollars of lost Revenue
and uh in contrast to the way it's
written in the testimony I believe
you're saying that that's the impact on
New Hampshire alone
the the report which is called the the
title of which is a simple fix
um looked uh nationally looked across
you know every state and so there is a
chart in there that identifies the
potential loss in Revenue to every state
because of Water's Edge Provisions so
it's describing 177 million dollars to
New Hampshire citizens yes sir in the
chart you'll see New Hampshire and 177
million ascribed as the estimated impact
okay and third it's my understanding
that you're not
picking who the villain is here between
us-based multinationals and Forest
foreign-based multinationals doing
business here they are equally a problem
in the way you've described the issue am
I correct that's correct you know any
any multinational corporation regardless
of where it's based
has this accounting ability
um and and again the lack of uh required
reporting that would give New Hampshire
dra for example the ability to audit
globally their activities and compare
them to what they do in New Hampshire as
opposed to the way they do it today
which is we can you know we can audit
activities
in other states we simply can't
you know have any any International
aspect yes it's the international aspect
completely yes sir okay
um thank you very much and Mr Garr
thanks for the extensive history which I
found very helpful
um so
we'll dismiss this panel and before we
go on I just want to say of course we've
run well over the time allotted don't
fret I'm aware we might shorten our
lunch break and we'll just see how it
Paces along
um so thank you gentlemen thank you
so
yes
uh before we go to the the next speaker
uh allegation was uh or a statement was
made that uh uh raised a question in my
mind regarding
how businesses are report and dra is
here and I was hoping that uh we could
probably get
so the dra will testify at the end of
the line and I just
um a quick insight
the plan for this progression
anticipated that we would lead off as we
just have with some new hampshire-based
businesses who are advocates for this
proposal
and we're going to go through a variety
of different uh spokesmen and
perspectives including practitioners and
academic but we are going to conclude
with the dra and that's very much with
the idea that we end up on a practical
note in terms of what the actual hurdles
of implementation audit and enforcement
will be okay so there's a method
um so I'd like to uh welcome Meredith
Beeson senior director state government
affairs
who's here with us personally uh for the
global business Alliance and we also
have Ellen pasetsky uh her colleague
federal and state tax policy consultant
who's joining us over the video links so
ready to go uh good morning chair
spilsbury members of the study
Commission on worldwide combined
reporting my name is Meredith Beeson and
I'm here on behalf of the global
business Alliance it came up already so
I appreciate you reviewing some of what
we submitted I am here to express our
concerns with mandatory worldwide
combined reporting that you all have
been tasked with studying thank you for
the opportunity to share a perspective
on the negative impacts that a mandatory
tax policy such as this would have on
the state
the global business Alliance or GBA
proudly represents 200 American
companies with a global Heritage our
members are headquartered in 23
different countries all in places that
are allied with the United States and in
fact among all International employers
here in the state those from the United
Kingdom Canada and Japan support the
largest number of jobs
here
the mission of GBA is to defend and
promote an open economy that welcomes
International companies to invest in
America our members help grow New
Hampshire's economy and provide high
quality jobs in local communities across
the state in fact on average U.S workers
at International companies earn seven
percent more than the economy-wide
average over 50 000 people in New
Hampshire are employed by International
companies and almost half of those jobs
are in the manufacturing sector and
another great statistic is that
employment from foreign direct
investment or FDI has increased by 22
percent in the state while the state's
overall private sector employment has
sadly decreased by one
it is clear that International companies
are a vital part in creating a resilient
economy economy but our members also
rely heavily on small businesses across
the state that provide essential
Services equipment and products I
submitted a fact sheet for you all to
learn more about our members
contributions to the state so let's now
talk about mandatory worldwide combined
reporting no other state in the Union
has taken this approach
making a single tax approach mandatory
like worldwide reporting can cause a lot
of volatility volatility and shifts in
Revenue about half of states have
adopted some form of what is called
combined reporting however again none
have imposed mandatory worldwide
combined reporting
in our work here in New Hampshire and in
other states that have looked at this
mandatory worldwide approach we've
actually heard from some of our
companies that their liability would
decrease leaving the state with less
revenue and more volatility but more on
that in a bit
states that have considered this tax
policy have decided against it for a
number of reasons including the lack of
predictable Revenue this worldwide
policy could also have international
ramifications and create unnecessary
disputes with countries that are key
trading partners with the United States
this is at a time when Global
Connections are needed most
worldwide reporting as was mentioned was
first debated in the states in the 1980s
and some foreign governments even
threatened to retaliate against the
United States companies if these
policies were adopted their concerns
were that these policies would unfairly
tax International companies and as a
response States created a filing option
allowing for what is called the true
Waters Edge system this generally means
including only U.S companies in the
combined group every single state that
offers worldwide as a filing option make
sure to have this Water's Edge approach
and whenever a state considers any form
of combined reporting GBA Advocates
generally for only the inclusion of U.S
companies in the tax filing group this
is what New Hampshire currently does
this allows for fair Taxation and
respects the principles of tax treaties
by contrast worldwide combined reporting
looks to tax a portion of the income of
an entire Global Group again not a
single state has mandated worldwide
combined reporting and if New Hampshire
adopts this mandatory approach it will
make the state a complete outlier
if this changes taxpayers and state tax
administrators alike are faced with
considerable challenges issues like
managing currency conversions different
Accounting Standards various reporting
requirements and even language barriers
to name a few
as I stated at the beginning and of
particular importance to everyone here
that helps set the state's budget
mandatory worldwide combined reporting
creates Revenue volatility
unpredictable revenue is a byproduct of
any kind of combined reporting which
could increase or decrease the revenues
collected by the states
states such as Virginia and Maryland
explored regular combined reporting but
neither adopted any form of it so for a
mandatory worldwide approach that
Revenue uncertainty is exponentially
greater Not only would it require
foreign company profits but also Global
losses to be included in a combined
return proponents of mandatory worldwide
policies say it will bring in
unprecedented Revenue but their
methodology uses several troubling
assumptions many of these studies for
example were done before major federal
tax reform even went into effect and are
not accurate
if the state adopts mandatory worldwide
combined reporting unpredictable
revenues are not the only issue the
state could see a dramatic increase in
audit activity and prolonged litigation
exposure which creates risk
if this policy is imposed it will hurt
efforts to attract and retain
International companies and damage the
state's overall economic competitiveness
so to recap my thoughts again no other
state in the Union has taken this
approach while regular combined
reporting has been implemented in New
Hampshire and many states not a single
one has imposed mandatory worldwide
reporting the state should preserve
their current approach and avoid double
taxation of income or retaliation from
foreign governments if imposed worldwide
combined reporting could not only cause
erratic Revenue but could reduce
corporate tax collections which is
dangerous when funding the state's
priorities
please consider how this policy could
damage future growth and hurt
relationships with key trade allies
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today I will now turn it over to my
colleague Alan pazetsky to to provide
thanks Meredith I hope you all can hear
me uh hello chair spilsbury members of
the commission good morning you're loud
we are still very members of the
commission my name is Alan passetsky and
I'm a tax policy advisor for gbda
I have a unique perspective of working
as a federal and state tax leader for a
large corporation for over 30 years
which included dealing with all aspects
of taxes including Audits and compliance
I cannot emphasize enough to this
commission the Myriad of issues that
mandatory worldwide combined reporting
will create the New Hampshire
this state has prided itself on good tax
policy for individuals and businesses
and is often ranked as a favorable
destination for investment in fact I was
up in Concord in April testifying in
support of SB 189 which allows
corporations to take a tax deduction for
interest on loans that can be used to
invest in the state
this bill passed unanimously and was
signed by the governor because this
state continues to acknowledge that
taxes should not be an impediment to job
growth I would like to thank all of you
for support on that very important bill
but if you were to implement mandatory
worldwide combined reporting now the
state would be going backwards and it
would undo all of the Goodwill New
Hampshire has built up to encourage the
business and the community to invest and
create jobs
worldwide combining is not a new concept
as you have heard when the states first
started started to adopt these proposals
decades ago it was insanely complicated
and produced long drawn-out audits as
well as other issues which Meredith has
raised earlier
other than perhaps the good music of the
1980s there is no reason to go back in
time and revisit tax policies that were
deemed harmful to Americans and American
workers it should be noted though that
New Hampshire unlike many states already
taxes certain foreign income including
dividends some of this Revenue collected
from that foreign income could actually
be compromised with a change to
mandatory worldwide combined reporting
another thing I could speak to firsthand
is the huge administrative burden to do
calculations for a worldwide tax return
you may hear from others later today who
have never worked internally for a
business but these worldwide
calculations are extremely complicated
think about it is the person that's
doing taxes for business based in
Manchester supposed to reach out to
company contacts around the globe
International companies may not be
willing or be able to share private data
not knowing where it may end up
the relevant profit and loss data that
will need to be collected will not be
calculated in U.S currency U.S
accounting or U.S tax principles
this complexity will not only be
challenging for companies but for the
state requiring additional audit staff
and resources not to mention the
eventual onslaught of litigation that
will result
in addition to almost complexity as
Meredith indicated one of the biggest
issues you should consider is the
unpredictable impact this may have on
your Revenue no one can honestly tell
you what the income or loss of
international companies around the world
will be annually or the impact on New
Hampshire's revenues the bottom line is
that the impact will be dependent upon
the global facts for each company's
group and which company is globally are
allowed to be included in the group
again this policy would make New
Hampshire a complete outlier and I urge
you not to gamble with a controversial
tax system that is unknown Revenue
results creates complexity and deters
investment thank you and we are happy to
thank you Mr chair Jordan ulery Hudson
uh representing Hudson
listening to the testimony that you've
given thus far into the uh the
I'm a little concerned that using that
that large employer here in New
Hampshire
if that company were to have a loss in
say shipbuilding and
Northern England
could they not then just shift as a
business cost
anything that the profits that were made
from selling
avionics in New Hampshire
in England and that would be under
worldwide reporting a legitimate shift
of funds to cover business expenses so
there would be no taxation in New
Hampshire because it's a business
expense
it it was that a scenario that could
exist
I'll start it off Alan and then you can
chime in I think one of the things that
I wanted to underscore in our testimony
was that the idea of global losses
aren't often accounted for when the
proponents are talking about the
estimations of Revenue included so
you're exactly right if you mandate all
of these subsidiaries or foreign parent
to be included into a combined group
without any connection to New Hampshire
operations you could change the
apportionment of how a company would
need to file or be liable for taxes paid
in New Hampshire right so it could
reduce that Revenue that the state
eventually collects because there's
Global losses being folded into a group
than just the single sales Factor
Alan anything to add on that
no I think that's just a good point
people think about this as it's
worldwide it's the entire world group
first of all it is only certain members
of the group that meet certain criteria
the dra can comment on that later but
there has to be a connection of some
sort between the foreign company and the
U.S company whether it be ownership of I
mean common officers a shipment of goods
or is a whole plethora of of issues that
could get you included and those rules
are very subjective so first like you
said representative
you could bring in losses you could
bring in losses of certain companies and
not others this is a Pandora's Box that
would be reopened for basically no
reason because as Meredith said the
revenue and certainty drives the
representative chamber
thank you representative Tom Schamberg
uh Merrimack six
uh
first question for you
do you know what the purpose of our
tax uh
policy is for New Hampshire
um
what is the first I'm not trying to
understand that question well I I just
want to make sure that that
we understand what we're trying to do
for the citizens of New Hampshire Our
obligation to the citizens of New
Hampshire
is to assure a fair and Level Playing
Field for its taxpayers and our tax laws
have to make sure that they are fair and
level and this is probably the only one
that really really
has some deficits to it
for policy I know
so let me let me try to answer the
question
the policy you currently have let's look
at this whole country and then we'll
focus on New Hampshire okay as earlier
testimony indicated companies can file
basically in two ways as a separate
company each U.S company files a return
to New Hampshire or is a group You a New
Hampshire chosen combined reporting
of those U.S companies about 27 States
sold roughly about half of the country
had that kind of reporting it has been
determined by almost all these states
that that is an appropriate method of
reporting
you can argue both ways what's exactly
the right amount of tax we don't know
but as far as not creating a playing
field globally
global companies and earlier testimonial
represented uh mentioned Home Depot
which is a U.S company again
International but U.S based we all had
the same tax returns to file we all have
the same calculation of income and loss
to come down to taxable income with the
same New Hampshire tax rate
do certain companies have advantages
because they have foreign Affiliates
well they have they have a situation
where they could pay expenses to a
foreign affiliate because that's where
they're Incorporated that's where they
are set up the company I used to work
for was established long before there
was a federal income tax code
and one it was an earlier testimony
again I'll keep referring to where it
talked about paying a licensing fee of
Pharma companies because they transfer a
patent well if it's an abusive situation
it can be dealt with the auto level or
in the federal audit level but if that
company established that patent because
it was incorporated in the Netherlands
in 1845 at all of their patents are
there and now that company has to pay a
license fee to use that patent that is
legitimate business expense and doesn't
create an unleaval field because for the
companies that are us-based companies
Pharma companies and the like they would
have the patent in the U.S and they
would receive that licensing income it's
really a matter of General business
setups
organization that is established that
way and again I think to representative
Shamrock a lot of the focus is going to
be on abusive transactions and we don't
shut down a street because a few people
are jaywalking I think those abuses if
they're out there need to be addressed
by Auditors at the state and federal
level
may I follow up with another question
either for Meredith or for Alan
um
regarding the statement about the
uh
complexity of trying to
does the dra
in New Hampshire would you say they have
the authority to require the
corporations to report
that information that we we need to
determine their tax liability uh
directly on their New Hampshire
Corporation corporate tax returns
could that be done
and follow-up on that one is you talk
about complexity of languages and things
like this
what is the basic language that we use
in
across the world today
uh so uh representative Schamberg I'll
take a first pass you know I definitely
want the department to speak on I don't
want to speak on the Department's behalf
I think they can require certain
information but again I think it is
challenging for companies when you're
managing conversions and different
accounting standards across multiple
different countries and languages do
still vary I I'm not as familiar and
I'll turn it over to Alan to to take it
from a a Global Perspective but I do
think that there's still various
different tax return information like
different governments don't have the
same type of lines that we do at the I
you know Internal Revenue code and when
a federal tax reform is or federal tax
filing is done here it looks different
than a Swiss tax return or a Canadian
tax return and that's not just language
yeah Meredith I I would agree I mean
think about it again
your foreign parented headquarters
you're likely representative Shamrock to
help me language that everyone speaks
maybe English depends on the country but
that's not what we're talking about it
we're talking about
a company in the U.S in New Hampshire
now having to decide which of its
Affiliates around the world belong in
its group based on the facts
of that affiliate and it's interplay
with the U.S company which means I'm
gonna have to have my state tax person
reach out to say someone in South Africa
or in you know Brazil or in any country
and have a thorough discussion on
whether that company perhaps should be
in the group and if it should be in the
group how to get their income which will
be computed on a completely different
principles
tax returns in other countries are
nothing like ours every country has
their own different system they don't
even stop at the sales often they start
at different levels and build up to
translate that into a consistent Apples
to Apples calculation to be used in a
New Hampshire tax return
so it is a very complicated calculation
and then the dra will have to audit that
and I don't know how they have the
resources to determine
if those numbers are even remotely
accurate
thank you for that answer in the last
I have my third question I don't want to
lose strength do either one of you know
if there was ever a secret Arrangement
between the US government through the
White House with Great Britain to move
away from worldwide combined reporting
uh with States like New Hampshire and
California
representative Schamberg I'm not
personally familiar with that I do know
a lot of countries threaten to retaliate
if states did pass bills so there was uh
you know if measures were they were
waiting in the wings if States moved
forward with Worldwide combined
reporting so I hope that answers your
question it sort of answers it
thank you yep
questions from other members
I'm one question Ms Beason you mentioned
that you have 200 members I imagine if I
went to the website I might find a list
but can you provide us a list of the
members yes absolutely thank you yeah
thank you um I I have a question yes Mr
Kennedy relative to the issue of
retaliation from the foreign entities
and things like that
um do you have any
anything
even speculative as to like what that
looks like in terms of potentially
businesses not coming in or leaving the
the state because we move to to this and
and in conjunction with that assuming
companies didn't retaliate didn't leave
the state
um there have been numbers that have
been indicated that if we move to
worldwide reporting uh revenues would
increase by a significant amount
um is it your sense that if there wasn't
a retaliation that moving to worldwide
reporting would increase revenues to the
state and and then I presume your
argument is that yeah might potentially
it would go revenues might go up if
nobody left but the the offset to that
is companies would leave so revenues
would go down I'm just trying to to
understand your your position on the the
controversy between those two ideas yes
thank you for the question I think it's
worth clarifying that when we use
retaliation it was actually retaliation
by other governments against U.S
companies who do business in those
places right so I'm not saying on behalf
of our members that individual companies
would retaliate or choose to leave I
think they might might have a lot of
complexity and additional burdens when
they're putting together these worldwide
calculations
but I want to underscore that U.S
companies might be hurt by all the other
countries that try to respond and do
something similar right so that is that
notion of the retaliation piece and I
thank you for the question on Revenue
you know I wanted to underscore that
some of our members actually like a
worldwide approach they like it as an
option and that goes directly to the
point of potential revenues could
decrease here in the state if this is
imposed because it does pick winners and
losers so some companies would pay more
in liability While others would see a
reduction in their tax liability and I
think that surprises a lot of people
because they assume by mandating a
worldwide group that it's just going to
bring in all these profits which again
are
not being it's not being considered that
Global losses would also be part of them
um one more question relative to the
complexity and certainly I think it's
understood that there would be various
levels of complexity by moving to to
this but
um
uh in terms of information gathering
the federal return requires a lot of
foreign reporting whether it's a 5471
and Reporting your subsidiary activity
or foreign companies with U.S operations
I'm interested in your response when
people say well no that information is
already available on the federal return
so the state would have less issues with
kind of compiling that information for
worldwide reporting what's what's your
response to when when people are
thinking relative to the reporting
Associated on the federal return
great question I think and I'll let Alan
back me up but the federal Consolidated
group is a very different group than
would be required under a state combined
return or World mandatory worldwide
return and I think it's a lot of moving
pieces right when you think of a federal
return as a company's usual Federal
Consolidated group and so a state tax
return what is connected effectively
connected income or what is connected to
activities here in the state it looks
different that group will look different
but you're right that any federal
amended return is also going to be
reflected on the state side right so if
an adjusted return is done at the
federal level then you've also got that
as a starting point with a New Hampshire
anything to add
yeah let me add a little bit yeah it's a
great question by the way um you know
you mentioned 5471 it's 5471s are formed
that certain companies file that have
foreign subsidiaries right so there will
be some data on those forms that perhaps
could be used here I guess we don't know
what the language would be what would be
required but
we are also talking about a much larger
group of companies that are not foreign
subsidiaries they're not on under the
U.S group
there will be no information or very
limited information in a U.S tax return
related to those companies
so it's two different groups of foreign
companies that we'd be looking at once
so if I can just follow up that
anticipated question I wanted to ask the
audit challenge
when an issue arises it's likely to
require reach into Data that goes beyond
what would be found in the federal
income tax return is that correct
okay see no more uh questions excellent
testimony thank you very much both of
you
thanks for
dialing in
okay
um our next presentation is from Walter
hellerstein distinguished research
professor and Francis Shackleford
distinguished professor in taxation law
Emeritus at the University of Georgia
School of Law and visiting Professor
Vienna University of economics and
business and Professor hellerstein has
come to us from Georgia so thank you for
there you go okay thank you very much
um it's an honor and privilege to be
here
and uh I guess as I'm listening to the
earlier testimony I'm sort of reminded
of of where I've been actually I want to
hit the button for them they're coming
up
your slide is looking good yeah I know I
get rid of that
yes
like I'm not sure I really need to go
beyond my first sentence
which is the it's my my favorite quote
from the U.S Supreme Court Justice
Oliver Wendell Holmes and
the longer history I live the more I
realize this is this is this is true
um that the history here
uh and the logic uh are not exactly on
the same page and I think it's really
important to understand how we got to
where we are
why we're here and uh you know maybe
what's the right way to approach this
and I want to say another thing these
are things I've been doing this for so
long that I you know I've said to
somebody else earlier that you know when
I get a call
um
a professor would you like to be an
expert witness I mean I've done I've
argued before The Supreme Court I've
represented clients and at this point I
say well
um
you know what am I going to say when I'm
you know testifying under oath
and uh I'm asked on cross-examination
well Professor didn't you say something
a little bit different in your Treatise
and I said oh yes your honor but I think
better for money oh the point I'm I'm
really here I'm hoping sir I don't you
know I think this is a complicated issue
um there are we've already heard two two
sides to this issue but I really believe
that one thing that may be very
informative and I realize you know my
time will be up pretty soon is just to
go through that history without
completely repeating what everybody said
but just to understand how we got to
where we are and what we might do given
um
the history it is the history that you
know that I think many of us sitting
around this table looking at gray hair
are familiar with uh you know is that
um
the the very notion of combined
reporting both on a domestic and a
global basis
was you know was something that
developed over the years in fact again
we take we take a step back when
everybody thought that
a separate entity meant
they work to be respected fully and not
uh you know don't tamper with what the
lawyers did don't tamper with where the
uh separate entity may be best based
whether it's in Delaware with a nice tax
Haven or in Ireland if you want to do it
globally
um and the standard for deciding where
income is earned was something that we
all I think familiar with particularly
at the federal level the arms length
separate accounting standard well again
to sort of fast forward I think we all
know that the States before we even got
to worldwide combined reporting
um they quickly understood first of all
they understood that formulary
apportionment rather than uh arm's
length separate accounting was the
appropriate way to approach this and
again for much of my life I go over to
Europe and I I was explaining to the
oecd Jeffrey Owens who's you know good
friend of mine chairman of the the tax
part of the oecd explaining we'd have
debates formulary apportionment versus
separate accounting and I would explain
the history of formulary apportionment
and why maybe it made more sense because
that meant that businesses couldn't just
put their entity in particular
jurisdiction and pay fewer taxes and he
would say look this is the global
standard everybody understands its arm's
length pricing and it works pretty well
again let's fast forward then through
the through the fact that the states all
developed
adopted embrace the notion that
formulary a portion we do it by formula
we don't try to pretend that if I sell
something from New York into New Jersey
we're going to figure out what would be
the if you had two unrelated entities
what would be the price of that sale we
we put them all together fine and then
we get to the point of the mid-1970s and
the 1990s when it's states started to
realize that wait a minute
as the universe expanded
um the system we have some nationally
um
or at least the system we have uh you
know within the states the formulary
apportionment that everybody accepted by
the you know there was no question about
that by the 1950s they didn't have or 60
States didn't have arms line separate
accounting but now the question is how
far does that go when you're dealing
with lots of related corporations and
again
not to you know repeat too much
everybody knows about container that was
the sort of them and I think one thing I
wanted to point out I look through there
the if you look at the the dates of the
cases that actually litigated this the
dates were 1983 for container and 1994
for
Barclays but in fact the actual tax
periods were much earlier for example uh
the the tax date in Barclays was 1977.
so the point is in some ways the the
universe had already moved by the time
the court decided these cases but
basically in both container uh you know
in the 70s and 80s uh
States realize that they should include
all related entities that are engaged in
a unitary business I don't need to
explain that to anybody and we shouldn't
just stop because I've happened to set
up a a business in the Grand Cayman
Islands rather than in Delaware
um
let's
well so the um again the
I think we've already heard some of this
today uh multinational corporations very
understandably said this is going to be
this is terrible you're now you're
you're putting everything into the same
pot we have this well-accepted standard
of arms line separate accounting that
everybody knows how to deal with at
least everybody in the global context
and now you're you're creating all these
problems
um you're going to create a risk of
international multiple taxation you're
going to prevent the United States I'm
speaking with one voice remember we're
talking sub-nationally globally
globally it's honestly in separate
accounting and has been but again just
to fast forward Beyond My Testimony
guess what folks there's a huge debate
going on globally about how businesses
should be taxed and maybe the arms Lane
separate accounting will be maybe along
when I'm gone you know buy something a
little bit different perhaps what we're
talking about now or you have the oecd
and the world talking about formulary
apportionment for part of a tax base uh
and understanding that maybe the the
pre-existing arms length separate
accounting Norm is you know whether
maybe a thing of the past at some point
not yet we're still at the position
where orange Lane separate accounting is
the norm globally but I think it's
important to understand this difference
what's going on sub-nationally and
internationally so when we early on said
it was a problem creates the risk of
international multiple taxation because
states are doing things that are
different from what the global community
is doing these are arguments that were
made I'll keep going here and in
container the court looked at that and
said you know
um
these are good arguments the people who
go by the hour make them and they make
them well but
um the risk of international multiple
taxation was not inevitable indeed if
you look at different different
determinations of the arms lengths
price and two different jurisdictions
you could have multiple taxation
um uh should California give up one
method in other words neither is perfect
I think that's something that maybe some
of the folks behind you are going to be
nothing formulary abortionment is not
perfect but neither is arms line
separate accounting
um although again if I'm a tax now
billing by the hour and I say yes I'm
going to set up just to give you another
example of the one I've lived through uh
you know you know I like Jeffrey
remember Jeffrey the giraffe
okay Jeffrey uh you want you went into
the Toys R Us and you bought something
from Jeffrey and guess what there was
um you know money was made including
royalties paid for that very nice
picture of the giraffe well guess where
all the world he's repaid to Delaware
Delaware which didn't tax so I've said
it was separate subsidiary to make sure
that none of the other states could tax
a piece of the royalties that wouldn't
exist that you hadn't made the sale into
the state where they were purchased well
we got over that we realized at the
subnational level that we can deal with
that whether it's through combined
reporting or by by the way saying that
there's there's Nexus over the the
company that is directing all this
attention to Toys R Us in the state of
Georgia but just
moving on
um the court rejected the possibility
they're real they're not made up there
are problems foreign retaliation
frustration of federal policy arms think
but the court said look
this is National we we we're dealing
with constitutional issues we don't if
Congress tomorrow persuaded by the
business Community wants to say that
it's a violation of the foreign commerce
clause which is congress's power to to
have the states do anything other than
arm's line separate accounting they can
do it
but Congress court has to say that so
when Barclays again becomes even more uh
the case involving a foreign based
company not at least containers the U.S
company same questions were raised that
the uh you know if California can
require arm's length separate accounting
it's going to create all kinds of havoc
uh in terms of how States comply and
very expensive and these are not made up
at the end of my I'm going to tell you
now to skip to my conclusion I'm not
coming in on one side or the other but
just understand how we got to where we
are and why we have this debate and it's
a real debate and I'm not sure either
side
you know I wouldn't take you this hour
on a contingency let's put it that way
um move on
uh okay and Barclays again we all all
the issues that are being raised here
were addressed by the U.S Supreme Court
um and again they dismissed them not
because they were frivolous but just
because these General requirements that
states must abide about they can't
discriminate against interstate commerce
we can't say in Georgia that anything
made in South Carolina that's sold in
Georgia is taxable or anything I would
probably like to but anything made in
Georgia Southern Georgia isn't can't do
that
um but the point is these General
constitutional restraints which are
understandable the court said we are we
are we cannot we can't impose those
sorts of requirements on the states
um Congress obviously has the power to
do that
keep going
um then what happened and here's my page
of History right so the U.S Supreme
Court says you know there are issues
here but we think the states are acting
reasonably at least they're acting
within constitutional parameters to be
doing what they're doing
and to have not just
combination but worldwide combination
if someone can show that this worldwide
combination
imposes a tax that's out of complete
proportion to what's going on in the
state taxpayer wins because that
violates the Commerce Clause and
probably they do Process Clause but to
say as a general principle that states
can't do whatever the federal government
has done
under federal law that we're not in a
position to do anything about it so now
let's get to where we are now
we after after container what happened
and here I the best thing I could do I
hadn't looked at this through this on my
shelf haven't read this stuff for
hold it up to the people on the screen
too this is the final report of the
worldwide unitary
unitary taxation working group August
1984 right time flies when you're having
fun
um and by the way remember this was 84.
container was 83. this is one year after
container and long before Barclays and
there there is a and again I don't have
three hours but I think this is
something worth reading bottom line
um the
the
world this group which was a federally
created group under Ronald Reagan
um
said we really need to deal with this
problem
through Federal legislation and that
that makes sense right Court said we're
not going to do anything so what are you
going to do you got to you go to the
legislature what should happen is this
Water's Edge we should have we should
have Water's Edge combination that means
combination's fine we're not rejecting
that but if you're if one of the
entities does much of its business
abroad 80 80 percent
they're they're not going to be you
shouldn't really include them because it
creates a lot of the problems we've
heard the business Community talk about
um what we also should have is increased
federal administrative cooperation with
the states let's all work together
states in the federal government to
create a nice good system nationally and
sub-nationally
um and let's have competitive balance we
don't want to you know foreign
multinational shouldn't should be
treated no no better no worse than
purely domestic businesses
um and of course guess what there is a
failure to to re to reach agreement no
big surprise
and by the way I have to
um I was in 1985 I just
um uh again the the 84 report says uh
States should adopt
um legislation uh but there is a certain
uncertainty about this I thought one
thing that was very interesting and I
don't know how many of you remember
Byron L dorgan who is a senator from
North Dakota and North Dakota was a very
uh in terms of Taxation it was I would
say I don't know uh it was on the front
end of doing what states might be
businesses might complain about them and
dorgan wanted to know because he kind of
liked what he saw
he said uh
dude I just remember the response from
the GAO the government kind of this
request this report responds to your
request for information on California's
experience in conducting formulary
enforcement of multinational
corporations and issues that would have
to be considered before adopting a
formulary system at the federal level
you know some people in the federal
government thought what the states are
doing makes a lot of sense why arms Lane
separate accounting formulary
apportionment understands you got to an
economic unit and maybe we should assign
this based on
where the activity takes place under the
state system would have been a where
your people are your property is or your
payroll where your where your where your
people are labor or your property is
capital and where your sales are that
was the notion that is the notion under
the three-factor formula well what's
happened since then again
I think maybe even though I may not be
talking directly about a lot of this
stuff this is really relevant a lot of
things have happened first of all
in response to let's just get the
response to the to the working group
um
and that's why we're here
um in in response to the threat of
federal legislation state after state
after State basically repealed or
limited worldwide combined reporting
um and I'll get to the this is the this
is the key key slide right with the
highlight of New Hampshire
um they all essentially depending on
what side of the street you're on you
know they caved in to the pressure from
whether it's Japan or the federal
government or good business lobbyists
and they all with a very few exceptions
uh adopted
legislation that restrained worldwide
combined reporting was this a matter of
you know thoughtful academic
determination no I think it was a it was
it was lobbying there were real issues
um but I think that's to where that's
whereby by by 19 you know interesting by
1991 all states had adopted Waters Edge
legislation I think someone ironically
it was in 1993 that the
Court in Barclays actually addressed the
constitutionality of what the states
have been doing in the past but we're
now
um had now voluntarily and I put that in
quotes decided
um they did not did not want to do and
again I want to get uh get get get back
to where
um you know where we are now and then
take any questions I hope some uh as to
what what we might do and there's one
other thing I want to refer to again the
the states basically adopted no the
state's abandoned worldwide combination
for reasons that I've suggested I think
largely for political reasons not that
not that the political arguments are all
nonsense but just that that was they
were motivated by that rather than I
think saying what's the best way indeed
if the federal government had listened
to Byron dorgan maybe we would all have
formulary apportionment at the national
level and wouldn't be talking about this
and by the way just to say this again
International level they're thinking
about that right formulary apportionment
is now part of the global
pillow I know how many people know
pillar one pillar two how we should
apportion income at the global level and
there's a big debate about that
including that market States ought to
get a piece of the piece of the of the
pie as it were even if you're not doing
if you're not physically there so maybe
if and pillar two how you know how do we
really how do we deal with all these
problems and finally
now I I come back to where I sort of
started
um the the rush for for you know to
restrict combined reporting didn't grow
out of the philosophical conversion from
formulary apportionment to severity
accounting you know I think they yielded
to economic and political pressures
which may be
somewhat legitimate but I think that's
that's really where we are today and I
think it's important to hear obviously
for both sides but also maybe maybe from
the middle and here's what I want to end
with
leaving maybe too much time for
questions but I thought as I was going
through my files that's what I do these
days uh in some way almost one of the
most interesting pieces of documents
that I think everybody should read uh
how not how many here know about the the
combined reporting study of Indiana
anybody familiar with that okay
um it's because Indiana
in October 2016 and what's good about
this this is a this is a more you know
we're 20 years later when the Universe I
think is that we live in is more
understandable and they wanted to
consider since Indiana was they were
just definitely unlike most States they
didn't even use combined reporting it's
separate company reporting and what this
study does
it analyzes the costs and benefits of
combined reporting and that's I think
what we that's what you guys need to do
what are the obviously some costs and
there are obviously some benefits and I
think
the answer is not clear
um I'm just going I'll just read your
part the executive summary is uh while
combined reporting neutralizes several
planning strategies like the use of
intellectual property holding companies
transfer pricing to captive real estate
captive for good it could also create
different complexities in the
determination of the unitary group
um again I'm not going to read them all
to you I just wanted to get to the I
mean I think the the the the ultimate
conclusion
and this is what I maybe where I'm going
to end for the moment yeah we use
economic techniques to examine how state
tax policies including combined
reporting influence state corporate
income tax revenue this method controls
for variation of the tax base related to
the economic cycle and other tax
policies and the impact from combined
reporting the economic results suggest
that combine that combined reporting may
have an initial positive impact on
corporate income tax revenue but that
this impact is not lasting we estimate
that the positive initial positive
impact could potentially be economically
significant however we also estimate
that the impact will only be short-term
and will decline to zero in the long run
so again I'm not weighing in on that but
I just think what everybody around this
table ought to do is read look at the
history and again I think this 2016
report is pretty interesting because
that's just saying should Indiana even
just go to combined reporting
and as I say at the end of testimony
when I used to give it further Affy and
okay thank you very much
can you send us a link to that study the
Indiana one oh yeah yeah I mean and the
1984 working group well oh well this
okay yeah sure I can send you links to
to everything yeah good good on that
before we leave I'll talk to somebody
who just I'll just give you show you the
representative already has a question
yeah
actually three questions oh good three
oh this question is the same one that I
asked previously regarding legitimate
business expenses and transfer funds uh
from this company because of the loss
and another division
somewhere around the world
that would under combined reporting
could
the revenue that would be due to the
operations within New Hampshire be
transferred to pay for a lost lead
because of some developmental process
taking place
uh in India or England or wherever
under combined reporting that the point
is that you would you would ignore you
would you would treat you would combine
that's why it's called combined
reporting you would basically combine
all the income
you'd have to have a standard for
determining the income of
all the related companies
and then you would say where that income
earned based on your formula again
looking back to the
earlier time when States refused some
where's the property where's the payroll
uh where where are the sales or today
where are the sales I mean you use a
formula to take the combining so you
wouldn't worry inter-company
transactions would not you wouldn't have
arms Lane separate accounting
determining did they lease to their
Grand Cayman Island subsidiary at a
so okay so under this combined reporting
would be the entire but you'd still have
to have some sort of Nexus within New
Hampshire as to what New Hampshire you
would only only one you would only have
to have only one
of your
entities would have to have Nexus so you
could have one entity with a bunch of
you know people and property in New
Hampshire and everything else
abroad but everything they were doing
was intricately related to what was
going on in New Hampshire and they would
the apportionment formula would include
the income of the combined group
assigned to New Hampshire based on the
regarding Hampshire which changed
the perception of Nexus to point of this
well it didn't real here's okay it's
good this is my page of History which is
good um remember I told you about the
Jeffrey case uh the Wayfair no I know
you're saying wait for I'm talking
Jeffrey Jeffrey is the case involving
the giraffe and and actually involved
whether or not there is a connection if
all I do Jeffrey said hey all I'm doing
is is licensing my
licensing my uh image to folks and and
the court said that's enough what you're
talking about is a Wayfair where the
court early on decided that for income
tax purposes okay income tax purposes
you don't have to have a physical
presence quill said you did okay and
then when when the court then when the
court reconsidered the case they said no
you know
um we are not
we're not holding everybody to the
physical president we're not holding uh
income tax jurisdiction to the physical
presence standard and then Wayfair came
along and finally said oh of course we
mean the same thing that we said about
income taxation for sales and use
taxation so in fact the physical
presence standard in the indirect tax
concept sales tax vat uh has long that's
that's all a matter of History
if I can
if you understand what I'm saying no why
in other words
um the
um
the quill the case that the case that
reaffirmed
the physical presence concept
in the quilt case I've got you know
cited here it basically said it said
because there was an attack on the
physical presence concept long before
Wayfair case they said you know we're
not saying this applies everywhere but
in the sales and use tax context it does
so in the income tax context there has
long been what I'll call an economic
presence rather than a physical presence
concept at the sub-national level at the
international level of course if you've
got you know need to have a permanent
establishment or whatever the whatever
your global standard is depending on
whether you've got a treaty with the U.S
or not that may be different
okay I I
sorry that's just the way the law
developed yeah yeah it's an ongoing
discussion when we've had it in ways and
means repeal to hear uh yeah which leads
up to the next question
um
just based upon your research
uh business tax revenues under the
condition 1981 to 1986 were X
did they uh business revenues to the
states increase or decrease after 1980.
I I have no I cannot I don't I don't
know and I think maybe I think this
Indiana study may be very useful for you
yeah
very good other questions yeah
um you mentioned the oecd in kind of the
international yeah you know so I spend
most of my time these days yeah that's
going on and I was hoping
um you could help us just kind of
understand worldwide Water's Edge
inbound companies in outbound companies
right and the taxation thereof
um as a result of this right so
outbounds now we do have guilty
that comes into play and we have kind of
a charge coming up a dividend that's
coming up that's in the tax base
obviously for inbounds where we have a
lot of related Affiliates that aren't in
the group currently that would be
exposed if you could just kind of
educate us on that just to make sure
we're all no but all I can say yeah no I
I can't I can't I can educate you in the
one sense for what's going on in terms
of
um
domestic
National direct taxis not you know
federal income taxation how that affects
foreign Commerce that's all a question
for Congress and and some of the things
that are going on are not going on are a
matter of
um you know intense debate but that's
quite different from the debate that's
going on globally at the oecd where I
think there again I I like to say this
because I think there's better
recognition
at least by not by every country and not
by ever but a recognition that the
pre-existing system
does not fairly attribute income to
where it's earned I'll give you even the
probably the best example they always
say if if a company makes this Facebook
makes its money by when I log on or
whoever it is by knowing where I am I
say oh Walter I say you're in New
Hampshire how would you like to buy
something
how do you know I'm in New Hampshire
because I've just logged on to something
and my eyeballs have been sold
guess what
um so now the question is and then of
course I buy something and what's going
on globally is understanding that you
know even if a company is only selling
eyeballs in some jurisdiction some of
their income
ought to be attributed to that
jurisdiction not all
some I mean I'm just giving it so that
that's the there's pillar one and pillar
two so so under one of the pillars we
understand that there ought to be some
income attributed to Market
jurisdictions even without physical
presence
um and that's and then the rest of the
balances should be again the national
the international
uh regimes are trying to figure out
what's what's the best way for
traditional income based on where people
are located you know arms Lane separate
accounting or do we need to vary that
and make changes but that's all a moving
Target now it means there's not there's
not uniformed agreement I'm sure that'll
be long gone when they when as and if
they finally decide what the right
answer is and then the question is
whether or not you know the U.S agrees
um but anyway that's where we are it's
you know it's great for lawyers or for
people who are involved in this but
there's no you know you're not going to
find an answer there yet
but you will find at least the questions
are being every question is being asked
here today is a question that's being
asked all globally uh particularly
whether regard to income fortunately I
just have to say this when I go to oecd
I'm dealing with what's really the easy
issue it's sales vat we all know how vit
ought to work and we all know that
destination based is right and then the
only question is how to do it in a way
that's you know that makes sense to
other jurisdictions but there's not a
debate as to where
the uh consumption ought to be taxed
consumption to be tax per consumption
occurs it's consumption tax if you have
good morning thank you for taking my
question
um now I believe that the one of the
main concerns is that the uh the local
domestic companies are competing with
multinational companies that has
uh CFC so foreign subsidiaries and
therefore there's this risk of Base
erosion and profit shifting now New
Hampshire is conforming to the tax cuts
and jobs act and specifically we are we
adopt a guilty
um
for taxable income purposes
what is your thoughts on the mechanism
of guilty in terms of trying to Abate
the business uh the the base erosion and
profit shifting well very it's a great
question and I think it depends and
often do we say a terrible answer but
that's that's the right answer I mean to
what it what are you to what are you
conforming to are you conforming to
something that would attribute income to
U.S sub-national jurisdictions
um are you and you have to look and how
does it flow through what's going on and
again we just just had a recent uh issue
about you know should the should should
States conform to whatever the most
recent uh Federal development is and
again it's com it depends and I think a
lot of it depends
at the federal level all they're talking
about or not all that at the federal
they're talking about what's in the tax
base they're not talking about where the
tax base goes that's the arms Lane
separate accounting so I mean we talk
about whether it's guilty or talk about
other uh developments that are that are
at the federal level I think one has to
sort of translate that into
if you're just talking about the base
does the federal does the state think
that they like that change in the base
they normally would because States
normally conform to the federal unless
they decide not to so it's it's
complicated but you know
I think some of these materials would
help
yes representative chamber I'll try to
make this one short thank you Professor
alerson
um
Virginia undertook a study like I didn't
know about the 2016 Indiana yeah you did
I until you know so we're both in the
same class yeah all right
and they're doing a comparison study
of what their present tax system is and
worldwide combined reporting and it's a
five-year program that they're running
so maybe you can look that up sometime
oh yeah but did they bait but I mean
they based on a hypo I mean based on
their existing existing with
hypothetical what would have happened if
you've done this interesting that's very
important okay uh the GAO
in 1993
so you're not talking okay GAO yeah the
GAO it's just a question about would we
have been better off will we will we
wouldn't we be better off moving to the
worldwide combined reporting versus what
we are presently doing because of what
they said then uh in their 18 and 1989
to 1990 tax data they
72 percent of foreign control
corporations pay no income tax and I
think that same thing is happening today
uh
the IRS experiences problems in dealing
with transfer pricing issues
um
even though they've moved to different
tools of the challenges of section 482
with global economy why wouldn't we want
to move toward a worldwide combined
reporting versus what we're seeing now
I'm in violent agreement with York with
your comment I think the answer is
um in a perfect world maybe even an
imperfect World
um the notion that we're going to
look at every separate transfer price to
determine where the income is earned I
think we've learned again a page of
History's worth of volume of logic
doesn't work very well I'm not saying
formula reapportionment works perfectly
but I think it works better and more
effectively given what's happened to the
economy and I do think it's fair to say
the global community at least you know
part of it not everybody from the
business Community but you look at it
there's been a recognition
given with the oecd governments at least
the goal on the government side that we
need a better way involving perhaps
formulary apportionment for at least
part of the tax base to assign it and
that arm's length separate accounting
well fine for the for the 20th century
let's say maybe not be the answer for
the 21st
thank you sir
yes Mr Kennedy thank you Professor
um relative to the erosion base that we
talked about and Mr Wong referred to the
federal government's kind of partly
responding to this transferring of
profits overseas and the guilty tax
um do you know if suppose that excluding
the the way New Hampshire treats guilty
but that there were Provisions in the
New Hampshire laws that basically
addressed this erosion-based issue or
transfer pricing rules or
um arm's length where they say if you're
a company in New Hampshire and your
costs include shipping things either
overseas expenses overseas or to another
state that we're going to do something
different and I know there's a lot of
equity issues in our state constitution
but if they simply say that you know
let's say you can only have have five
percent royalties as an expense and so
we're going to decouple maybe from the
the regular amount does that create any
sort of constitutional issues that you
can Envision if if New Hampshire's
decided to instead of going to worldwide
but look for a compromise that kind of
addressed
um uh this this exportation of profits
and simply kind of isolate it to
specific things does that create any
sort of I would say absolutely not
unless again unless unlike just a
general approach again states of adopted
formulary apportionment while the
federal government had an online
separate accounting and no one suggested
that the methodology a different
methodology at the subnational level is
per se inconsistent with what's going on
at the national level and indeed the one
case they that might support that the
idea a case called Japan line where the
question of whether a property could be
taxed both in the U.S and in Japan where
it was taxed
um if there's a if there's a complete
inconsistency between what the states
are doing what's happening
nationally and I would say should be
sub-national because what's going on
nationally shouldn't affect what's going
on subnationally you know maybe there
could be but not when you're in the more
general question you're asking
um is whether or not you know something
if whether
what's some rule for assigning income or
taxing income at the federal level does
not in no way binds the states unless
the federal government through its
legislative Authority decides that it
should be that's why we have a Commerce
Clause
thank you
thank you very much so
there was suggestion earlier that there
could be lingering commerce clause or
even 14th Amendment issues but none has
been raised and I'd like to please
confirm to me if this is an accurate
summary of what you've told us it's not
not in my no in my view again my gold
standard I would never go near you
wouldn't take it on a contingency a
because all you need for equal
protection is rational basis yes
certainly rational
um I I agree with you I just I wanted to
cut so so as it stands in terms of the
body of Supreme Court case law
and the various actions of the United
States Congress there is nothing from a
constitutional perspective or from a
preemption perspective that currently
binds our hands the legislature of New
Hampshire effectively is free to make a
judgment call perhaps in in the context
of the Indiana study we need to
recognize that there are pros and cons
mitigating against each other but
ultimately it's a judgment call it's a
matter of Economic and tax policy I I
think that is precisely right on the
Assumption again that in that in the
legislation in the hypothetical
legislation there's no wrinkle that says
that provides any specific Advantage
formulary apportionment versus orange
Lane separate accounting fine
but formulary apportionment that you
know doesn't count
um you know out-of-state people problem
okay understood yeah so we can only be
so adventurous
very good thank you that was extremely
thorough very interesting and I'm going
to read a lot more carefully what you've
submitted oh no thank you very much and
I will give the you know the
links to to these documents but the
Indiana thing was most important one
there sorry thank you bye yes very good
thank you Mr chairman yes sir
um we've been using some jargon uh and
this is open to the public so maybe we
should explain what the jargon is uh so
one of the accounts would like to
which particular jargon are you I was
just thinking of guilty because
Global uh unitary intangible intangible
yeah guilty is so it's it's a new
provision you know relatively new
provision from the 2017. from 2017 okay
it's Global intangible low taxed income
um and it it uh relates to controlled
foreign corporations so these are
corporations that are owned uh greater
than 50 percent by U.S shareholders we
got a further definition here so a U.S
shareholder is a U.S person which can be
a company an individual a partnership
you name it that's a person right under
the tax code in the aggregate they have
to own more than 50 percent
what this provision does is to the
extent that you own a controlled foreign
corporation one you have an obligation
to file of 54.71 okay we've heard this
form already this is an informational
filing that I spent this weekend working
on for clients and I wanted to put my
head through the wall uh it's very long
form it can be upwards of 20 30 pages
very robust reporting on this and so
when we talk about information being
available to the New Hampshire dra it is
important to acknowledge that these are
in that file but anyway so we have this
form and you calculate its profits on a
U.S tax base
and that is if it's a positive number
that's your tested income okay
you're also attributed a portion of kind
of their assets that are used hard
Assets in a Trader business taxes
if it was a loss it'd be a tested loss
okay it'd be a test of loss I then as a
US person you know either the
corporation the partnership what have
you that has these interest Aggregates
all of my tested income and tested
losses and that determines what my
guilty is global and tangible low-text
income I'm taxed on that that's in my
tax base
and so if I own foreign corporations
that are subject to transfer pricing and
the separate accounting that we've heard
about and all this at the end of the day
the net of everything at this point the
intention is get smashed together and
flows up to the owners
so as we think about that portion of the
separate accounting that's important to
acknowledge that's the intent of this
guilty provision
that's what it is in a nutshell two
minutes or less
very clear explanation thank you
okay just to preview where we're at so
we have
two presenters who are both linking in
through the video connection
they are scheduled for 11 11 30 and
we're just going to make it 11 30 and
noon and I'm afraid our lunch I think
should just be cut shorter to 15 minutes
we'll take a break at 12 30. and we'll
resume per the schedule at 12 45 so uh
I'm going to invite onto the screen next
uh Dan bucks he's a consultant with the
public revenues Consulting former
director of the Montana Department of
Revenue
good morning Mr bucks and thank you for
joining us
good morning Mr chairman members of the
commission it's a pleasure to address
you I'm sorry that I cannot be in um New
Hampshire with you I've traveled to New
Hampshire to talk about these issues in
the past and I've always enjoyed the
experience greatly and I uh respect a
great deal of a kind of deliberations
that the deliberations that you all are
uh engaging in today they're very
thoughtful and very careful
deliberations and great questions that
you've been asking the prior presenters
I'm going to talk here hopefully I'm not
going to take the full half an hour
but much less uh to to basically respond
to your questions and uh engage in a
conversation with you if I and and again
I hope I don't eat into the time uh too
much so that we do not have time for
conversation
um I uh I'm the former director of the
Montana Department of Revenue from 2004
to 2000 excuse me from 2005 to 2013 uh I
was the prior to that from 1988 up to
that point I was the executive director
of The multi-state Tax Commission uh in
both cases I was the person who served
the the the longest in each of those
positions in the in the history of those
organizations
um prior to that I was deputy director
of the Montana Department of the same
Department in Montana from 1981 until
1988 when I left uh to be executive
director of The multi-state Tax
Commission and I was in Montana During
the period of time of the intense
discussions that occurred litigation the
worldwide working group uh the the
rollback of of uh worldwide to Water's
Edge
I was in Montana at in that particular
period as deputy director and heavily
engaged in that prior to that I worked
in South Dakota and among my work there
I advised the governor on tax policy but
I had other duties as well but I advised
the governor on the adoption of a
corporate income tax at that time which
still has not been adopted in South
Dakota I also uh want to thank uh
Professor colorstein who preceded me
here for presenting a very thorough
presentation on the history and I'm
going to refer to that it's been very
helpful here and I'm going to refer to
that in my remarks here let me say out
of that history and I think the the most
important piece overall is that in both
the container decision in 1983
and the Barclays decision in 1994 which
incidentally covered two tax cases
Barclays and Colgate Palmolive
um the in both of those decisions
the U.S Supreme Court found that the
that worldwide combined reporting
as a required method was proper and fair
under the Constitution of the United
States
and it applied test tests not simply a
kind of legal constitutionality but they
applied the tests of fairness of
Taxation that the court has laid out in
the 1977 Complete Auto Transit case
and so that that I think you should be
the Touchstone of any deliberations
worldwide combined reporting is a an
entirely proper and fair method of
reporting
I'd also want to say
uh and you've had some vigorous
discussion earlier on administrability
that in the Barclays case and I'm going
to skip ahead in my remarks a little bit
here because I just want to make sure we
we get at this point in the Barclays
case
the court looked in particular at the
issue of whether or not worldwide
combined reporting created an excessive
administrative burden and and Barclays
in particular said that oh it would cost
them millions of dollars a year uh to
file the returns uh to comply with
Worldwide combined reporting in
California
in the end the court found the Supreme
Court of the United States found that it
would that would cost Barclays at the
time about 900 to 1200 900 to 1 200 not
millions of dollars
to file the required reports for
worldwide combined reporting and indeed
there was not an excessive burden but
that it was entirely administerable on
the part of the company to comply with
the other thing I would know and and I
was at that point in 1994 it was with
the
um the Morley State Tax Commission we
had filed an abacus brief in support of
California's position
and we have discovered on the last day
when we could file the brief and we
included it into the brief and brought
to the attention of the U.S Supreme
Court that Barclays had actually entered
a uh an advanced pricing agreement with
the federal government
uh just that year as that case was
proceeding that was premised on
worldwide combined reporting formula
apportionment so the
Barclays had already agreed to do
worldwide reporting had him I guess had
found an administerable from the
standpoint of the federal taxes but then
was arguing that it was unadminist rule
from the standpoint of a state
requirement and the court rejected that
I urge you to read the container and the
Barclays decisions those are the
preeminent guideposts for decision
making in my judgment for any state and
lays out why it is proper and fair in
terms of income reporting and why it is
in the case of the Barclays case
administrual
that worldwide combined reporting is the
only method of income taxation that
pre-preets businesses of different sizes
types and Geographic scale on an
absolutely equal basis it requires all
entities again regardless of type
regardless of size regardless of
geographic operations to require that a
hundred percent of the income that is
earned in the state that can be
reasonably assumed as earned being
earned in the state is reported to that
state
now I want to just say there was
criticism earlier about oh nobody
requires mandatory worldwide reporting
that's not right
every state in this country to the best
of my knowledge that Levy's a business
profits tax a corporate income tax a
corporate Franchise Tax based upon
income
requires the businesses that operate in
the united that operate in their state
small businesses that operate in their
state and if they use Waters Edge
reporting every business that operates
entirely within the boundaries of the
United States to report a hundred
percent of their income to that state
for tax purposes that's mandatory
worldwide reporting for small businesses
and if your water's edge for National
businesses the only ones that have a
special privilege
do not report all of their income are
multinational corporations if you don't
have worldwide reporting if you don't
apply the worldwide principle uh to them
as you are requiring the worldwide
principle to be applied to to small and
National businesses
and so that's I think that's important
to understand
that that really a Water's Edge report
gives multinational corporations a
special privilege to report less than a
hundred percent of the income that
they've uh earn in your state and and
not to pay a fair share of taxes that
they should for the services that they
enjoy the services that you provide that
benefit them and therefore they're able
to shift the burden of Taxation from
themselves
to your local businesses and to the
National businesses that are operating
within your state
now
it is the only the reason that Mali
National corporations
don't like worldwide combined reporting
is it it is the is that it is the only
proven and effective method
for stopping the shifting of income to
tax Havens to low tax jurisdictions it's
the only method that works and the
states prove that
and the when when they when they when
they had the tax uh the worldwide
reporting method in effect for
multinational corporations
now profit shifting is a huge problem in
today's world
and the world as Professor palerstein
related to you the world is now paying
attention to it today as it never did in
the 1980s that it is the world is
increasingly recognizing that it is a
problem that needs to be addressed and
is increasingly looking at formula
apportionment methods and indeed I would
say guilty for outbound uh transactions
uh in the United States guilty is a
rough form of uh and partial rough
partial form of formula apportionment
that says you have to bring back a half
of your income that you've shifted to
low tax jurisdictions and bring it back
to the United States so the federal
government is is has already opened the
door to a formula of apportionment type
method on a very rough basis and much
less much less precise and again than
this then the state's formula
apportionment system
and in addition as again Professor
hellstein emphasized that the that uh
the world now through the uh
organization of economic cooperation and
development is now looking at formula
style methods uh in in the pillar to
what they call pillar two of the of the
their deliberations
which is just a a label they've applied
to a set of recommendations uh they've
recommended a global minimum tax and on
top of that they put a possible
compensatory tax system where if a
corporation has shifted income to low
tax jurisdictions to tax Havens they
must pay a compensatory tax back to the
source of that income to the nation
where the income was actually earned a a
a a tax to compensate for the profits
that they shifted overseas
now what is that that is nothing more
than a form of worldwide combined
reporting operating not at the taxable
income level of a return but at the tax
liability level
now some business organization
Representatives say all the oecd has
rejected worldwide unitary well that's
because the oecd spent several decades
denouncing worldwide unitary as
practiced by States until they realize
that their arms length system was an
abject failure
and now they're moving towards in fact
formula apportionment methods and they
don't want to say directly and lose
Space by saying oh we're going to do
what the states in the United States did
instead we'll do it we'll we'll do
something else but that something else
is the same thing in a different form it
only it it operates a compensatory tax
system operates with Worldwide
calculations at the tax liability level
instead of the taxable income level so
their saving phase and when you hear
that they've rejected it that's not true
because in fact as the professor before
me indicated uh they are in fact
seriously considering moving in that
particular uh Direction the arm's length
method of accounting for tax purposes is
essentially dying and is judged as a
failure because of the massive nature of
the profit shifting that has occurred
now I'm going to
um I'm going to try to short-circuit my
comments here a little bit uh but just
talk about the nature of the extent of
the profit shifting that is occurring
in the world and the and the size of the
inequity that is occurring we don't know
exactly what the what it is because
there's not sufficient disclosure
required of of uh tax return information
to do an exact calculation although I'm
going to cite some that is beginning to
come out from tax disputes and and that
had have been studied here in a minute
the Congressional budget office has
estimated that uh 300 billion dollars in
profit is shifted annually uh to over uh
to uh other jurisdictions where it goes
untaxed and that correcting that would
amount to about 60 billion dollars a
year in federal revenue and if you uh
extrapolate to the states that would be
about 12 billion dollars in state taxes
annually that's on the low side
estimates other organizations have
estimated that it's up to a hundred and
nearly a 180 billion dollars in federal
taxes lost with a much larger uh part
accordingly being lost to the States now
so along comes some business
organizations who say well because no
one can agree on what the number is
there really isn't a problem those are
not reliable estimates well they're not
as reliable as we'd like them to be
because the tax returns have not been
sufficiently disclosed to do a precise
calculation at least as on a general
basis but that is changing Australia is
now requiring Company by company
reporting the financial uh uh Accounting
Standards Board is requiring increased
disclosure of uh of uh of tax
information and the uh and in addition
some Enterprise using tax economists and
and accountants of international
standing have begun to calculate from
tax uh uh dispute data the extent of the
problem and I commend to you an article
uh by uh Ruben aviona David Chamberlain
Stephen Curtis and Jeffrey Cadet in tax
notes Federal of May 22nd 2023 in which
they indicate and they they add to this
uh tax penalties and interest and I'm
not that a set of six companies and
they're named in the report
over a multi-period year period uh avoid
avoided
277 billion dollars in federal taxes and
those are a portion of those taxes
avoided were avoided in New Hampshire
incidentally and not successfully return
uh to your state at least not yet
uh so the problem is huge and they when
the business Community says well they
can't agree on the estimates all the
estimates are from the range of being an
enormous problem to being a
catastrophically enormous problem and so
somewhere in between enormous and
catastrophically enormous problem is the
problem that you face and I would urge
you to solve with the adoption of
worldwide unitary finally I'm just going
to say this is a general matter to you
I presided over the administration
of of worldwide taxes a worldwide
reporting uh taxes uh in uh Montana
uh we were still having remaining audits
when I was executive director of The
multi-state Tax Commission uh that
covered worldwide reporting years for
States when I was uh uh head of the
multi-state tax commission and we were
auditing corporations at that time
and again uh we uh when I was director
of Revenue Montana in the most recent E
Period of 2005 to 2013 we had a tax
Haven
um uh statute that combined tax Haven
income uh into the tax returns at that
particular point in time uh and uh in
all of those cases those laws those
worldwide and tax Haven laws were
entirely administerable and readily
administrable you do while there is
information from Federal Tax Returns
that is helpful and from State returns
that is helpful the fact is in that you
had these earlier questions about is
there information on those returns to
enable you to do uh the worldwide
reporting the answer is
not entirely but the information is
there in the public financial reporting
of the companies that is utilized for
this purposes and some of the smallest
states in the country including New
Hampshire North Dakota Montana and
Alaska which incidentally requires
worldwide reporting for oil companies
still to this day some of the smallest
states in this country successfully
administered uh the the worldwide system
and successfully audited uh corporations
for that purposes over a long period of
years California began worldwide
combined reporting their first case of
that was in 1939
and it was entirely administrable and
I'm just going to stop there and say
simply again that the operative words
are from the U.S Supreme Court uh
worldwide combined reporting is proper
and fair for the states to employ to do
justice to their citizens every other
taxpayer has to report a hundred percent
of their income and so should
multinational corporations thank you Mr
chairman members of the commission I'm
going to stop there I have a lot of
things I'd like to say about the
worldwide working group report Etc but
you can just ask me questions and I'll
try to be as responsive and as helpful
as I can be thank you
thank you very much and I don't know
that I have it yet so if you could send
us the link for the tax notes article
that you mentioned that would be helpful
yes yes I will I'm and I apologize for
not having uh submitted that earlier
Mr Kennedy
a couple quick questions regarding the
opposition to worldwide reporting so it
appears clear based on your testimony
that the state certainly could move to
worldwide reporting without
um uh suits or I mean there might be
suits anyway but they'd have a good
premise from the Supreme Court that
they're allowed to move to that but this
might open up the gate for um other
suits like what entities should be
included how do you apportion income
what about aggregation of ownership
um and so this could lead to additional
costs for companies and the state when
these sorts of disputes come up by
moving to worldwide reporting so I'm
curious as to what kind of response you
have to that and and the second to that
is the another opposition is that
foreign entities will the word when you
say is retaliate or perhaps the state
will lose business because
um worldwide reporting would mean
International companies would no longer
do business in New Hampshire so I'm
curious as to what your thoughts and
response are to those opposition points
uh yes uh and when I was saying that the
tax uh was administerable
uh I was including within that a
judgment as to the determination of the
unitary business group because that is
the beginning point with regard to any
kind of combined reporting we did that
we did that successfully in the 70s and
80s in a in a in a wide range of states
in a dozen States including again the
smallest states in the country
we did there is no record of inordinate
disputes in our in those small states
over the composition of the unitary
groups we did not have any more
difficulty with regard to multinational
as opposed to nationally based companies
or foreign corporations versus U.S
multinationals to my knowledge that's
the best of my recollection because we
just did not have inordinate cases uh
California did some rather sophisticated
methods of of uh of uh uh late in the
stage of their practices of de-combining
Etc some of the rest of us thought that
they were uh getting a little bit fancy
at that time that was more uh of a A
variation of that time that I think uh
was not uh uh necessarily consistent
with the longer term practices that both
that state and the smaller States had
engaged in and that was I think was an
idiosyncratic kind of situation that
arose late in the uh process of of their
use of combined reporting uh and I don't
think that was typical we hadn't we had
no greater difficulty applying the
unitary principle to form to foreign
multinationals than we did to U.S
multinationals or to National companies
operating within the United States
um as to retaliation
the last slide that Professor helenstein
had up referred to the fact that the
state's receipt it was not a pretty
picture in the 1980s when the states
were receded from Water's Edge
they were threatened with economic
damage by Foreign corporations saying we
will not locate we will not invest in
your States anymore if you don't repeal
Waters Edge now I will give you the term
that I apply to it others would find it
too strong but I considered that I was
present when that was message was issued
to the Montana legislature and I was
representing the department as deputy
director on legislative relations
I considered that then and I consider it
now to have been economic blackmail
and let me give you evidence of that I
was referred the letter that came to the
governor of the state at that time that
came from the um uh uh Mr Akio Morita
the head of the Sony Corporation and he
was also writing on behalf of the
Japanese business Confederate Federation
which is I've got a uh the the kadaran
the kaidanron I may not be pronouncing
that right but that's the Japanese
business Federation and he wrote this
letter
that said basically that if you do not
repeal worldwide unitary and adopt
Water's Edge reporting instead you will
not get any new investment from Japanese
companies in your state but if but the
implication was if you did repeal it
um you would get Investments and and so
they laid out the prospect
of computer chip plants and high-tech
Electronics plants of other kinds and
automobile plants that would arrive in
our state if only we would repeal
worldwide unitary
and under the threat of no investment
from those Japanese companies the state
of Montana the legislature receded to
the water's edge as they had urged
well it's 35 years later
we're still waiting for those computer
chip factories we're still waiting for
those automobile plants they never came
that was a phony threat it was I I just
it was a Despicable campaign that was
undertaken against the a an entirely
constitutional proper and fair practice
of the states that only asks a
multinational corporation to pay taxes
on the on the same basis as a small
business in a state as a national
business in a a pays taxes in a com
Water's Edge combined reporting state it
only requires equal compliance is all it
does
and to say that you want getting
investment for treating the company in
the same way that every other business
is treated isn't like in my judgment
reprehensible
yes representative ulery yeah rep Jordan
ullery from Hudson New Hampshire uh I've
asked this question of others you've
probably heard it regarding
um a company an international company in
New Hampshire with a loss overseas and
then turn just transferring the profits
over there and and showing uh uh uh
business loss therefore not having to
pay any taxes at all under either uh uh
business profits tax or uh I mean then
subject only to our business Enterprise
tax which is a tax on hiring people
how how would New Hampshire benefit from
a worldwide unitary uh taxation
if a business can just
write off their profits
to another division
well uh uh uh
Miss Sharon commission member I said I'm
sorry
thank you uh
the the answer is this is that if you if
you have a if you have a business that
is truly losing money in terms of the uh
if you if they're conducting a unitary
business in your state be it onshore or
offshore and they're truly uh uh losing
money in total
on on a real true basis yes they will
have that they will not pay taxes in
your state in that particular year
that's true because they are actually
truly losing money
but the and and that's fair in that
instance that yeah I'm talking about and
to uh if if that is truly the case but
what the reality is
is that uh and the reason why uh there's
a revenue gain and the reason why there
will not be Revenue volatility
is that that is not the typical
circumstance that is occurring
what is happening right now is that
states that the multinational foreign
multinationals both U.S and foreign
multinationals are generating artificial
losses
uh deductions against their U.S income
by by shifting profits overseas through
various mechanisms
sometimes they involve intangible
sometimes they involve other mechanisms
to tax Havens
and that those are artificial losses
that that are being deducted against
your tax returns today and what what
combined reporting does is end the
fictional losses and brings that money
back into the worldwide group and and
makes it taxable you're not going to
have a massive loss of Revenue because
of the situation that you've just
described businesses go up and down they
have profits and losses that's the
normal that normal business activity is
not going to generate overwhelming
losses in a given State what is
generating overwhelming losses right now
is the artificial shifting of profits
that they are earning in New Hampshire
right now and they're shifting it
overseas
uh and into tax Havens and what
worldwide combined reporting does is it
puts an end to that profit shifting and
you will have a net it I don't recommend
this on the basis that you're trying to
gain more Revenue you're only trying to
tax the revenue that you should fairly
tax and when you do that in the context
of the extensive
unacceptable profit shifting that is
occurring artificial profit shifting
that is occurring overseas there will be
a revenue gain produced and there will
be an anchor to your revenues that
decrease the revenue the effect of any
Revenue uh volatility because of the
normal business cycle
the profits that are being stashed
overseas and hidden from taxation are
enormous and they and it's a it's a it's
a practice that needs to be stopped and
all right thank you very much Mr bucks
um we have one further presenter before
we take our brief break
uh and
Darian thank you very much thank you
very much Darian chansky Martin Luther
King Jr professor of law UC Davis School
of Law and Mr shansky much like Mr bucks
has been a previous flyer with the New
Hampshire
legislature and provided advice so
welcome back again even though your last
visit was preceding me
well it's great to be back
um having grown up on the east coast and
been to New Hampshire I missed the fall
and I would I wish I were there in
person
um can I share my some slides is that
how Professor college team did it
you guys do slides yes we do
you do oh terrific uh we've got a
smaller image of you in the upper left
and a prominent image we also have a
um
okay so yeah I apologize my only issue
is I'm not seeing the slides myself so I
don't but I will just begin and build
them knowing where I'm at and hopefully
let me know so it's an honor to be here
I will go quickly I try to come up with
an agenda um that reflects
um the fact that I knew I'd be following
people who I want to say a lot of other
things I still manage to duplicate a lot
of what you've said I've been said
already so I want to leave as much time
as possible to answer questions so I
want to talk a little bit about New
Hampshire
um which most of course you know a
little bit about profit shifting about
the policy behind worldwide combination
and then mostly focus on responses to
objections
okay so if you see this live about New
Hampshire expenditures is that what am I
am I on say you're on uh the caption
ay sounds like you want to move ahead
too
right
just
embarrassed at this point in
virtual world that I'm not able to
operate teams and fashion effectively
I'll tell you what I would suggest just
go ahead because we do have uh just go
you have to slash in front of you so
I'll just go quickly so I have some
information just about New Hampshire
expenditures and revenues um from the
urban Institute from a high quality
report a lot of these reports are not
that high quality but the urban
Institute is so in New Hampshire is you
know slightly below average both in
taxes and revenues more interesting
um if you look at the um the the chart
on the third page is it actually shows
that New Hampshire in terms of its
physical capacity
um doesn't raise nearly as much as it
might so the hash is not really a low
tax state but it is a Frugal State uh
right one that punches um above its
weight and something that I presume um
you'd like to continue
um New Hampshire state taxes as I know
you've already talked about this is the
on the next slide
um has an unusual tax structure right
there's no General personal income tax
there's no general sales tax what New
Hampshire does have is the business
profits tax the business entities tax
and New Hampshire raises twice the
national average
um from its uh property tax
um the next slide is uh from your
Consolidated financial statements
showing that the BPT raises you know
something on the order of 700 million
dollars and as you know
is the largest single Revenue source for
the state
um it's also the next slide of the best
designed corporate income tax in the
country
um in part because it's the only
corporate income tax that doesn't just
tax corporate corporations
um there's no reason to not tax large
businesses the same as corporations I
tell that to other state legislatures
all around the country
um and at no success but but you are
doing um the right thing
um New Hampshire's business Enterprise
taxes in addition addition method
sub-national value added tax which is
also terrific and I talk about across um
of the country and so in lots of ways
New Hampshire has got its own way wisely
in order to raise money
um efficiently
so I I think that's at least for me
important context in terms of what we're
talking about
next slide I talk a little bit about
what profit shifting is I know this has
been addressed there are questions right
how does money get abroad um and the
answer is
uh Corporation with operations abroad
which is a simple example can shift
their intellectual property to a low tax
jurisdiction the low tax jurisdiction
charges royalties and profits are out of
the U.S tax base and into a foreign tax
Haven now the question is right how much
is it how big is the problem including
how big is the problem now after the tax
costs of jobs apps to the extent people
perceive that that act had Provisions
meant to counter
um tax shifting and so this is the next
slide so the current estimate is that
it's about 300 billion
um and that's again current right so
this is not historic so this is despite
the tax cuts and jobs act
um now the question is that well how
much would that mean
um for instance if that money were
brought back into the tax base how much
could that raise
um for New Hampshire the back of the
envelope calculation is working
backwards as to how much the percentage
of New Hampshire's tax base would
increase it gives us a number around 140
million dollars per year which I think
not surprisingly is about the same rough
estimate as the itap study arrived at
okay this is all back of the envelope I
miss providing this to you so you
understand that these are reasonable
estimates you a question arose well
shouldn't the IRS be doing something
um about this 300 billion dollars
leaving the U.S tax base yes
um they are failing
um of course it's not just the U.S
national tax Authority that's fairly
that's why the whole oecd is a flutter
about this issue but
but yes they should but they're not
next slide I have a couple of pictures
of just to show what tax shifting looks
like it means and if you look at the
first picture that in this case U.S
multinationals are booking enormous
profits in a head full of low-tax
jurisdictions and the profits are out of
all proportion onto the Assets in those
jurisdictions
um if you go to the next slide called a
more evocative debt slide
shows for instance that U.S
multinationals book profits in foreign
jurisdictions that are multiples of
those entire countries gdps and what
that illustrates right is that it's
clearly impossible for a foreign
corporations to be having profits larger
than the entire gross domestic product
of the jurisdiction in which those
profits are booked
final table is called picture of
opportunity shows a slide that about the
percentage of business profits that are
actually being successfully taxed
and you'll see it's a sad number right
that the federal government isn't doing
very well and the states are doing even
worse
um I call it a picture of opportunity
because it also indicates that if states
only do as well as they did in 1993 that
would be a gigantic increase to their
corporate tasks
okay so now to think about some
objections one common one right is well
nobody else is doing it and so the next
slide
um is a quote from Charles McClure whose
many ways the preeminent um tax
Economist of last decades and I've heard
him say use this analogy many times in
connection with trying to get states to
do the right thing about the sales tax
totally different issue at his point
right is that just because inexplicably
every other state is doing something
foolish uh doesn't mean that you should
as well and I would think again going
back to our introduction this argument
should be particularly appealing in New
Hampshire well you've already
demonstrated some interest in not just
doing the same foolish thing that every
other state is doing
um we need to ask right now what every
other state is doing but whether this
makes sex so if you go to the next slide
there's a picture of a building
um from England
um and it has the strange characteristic
and If This Were a law school class I'd
really draw this out but I'm not going
to waste your time
um that it's a picture of a way of a
building with blocked windows and you
know you don't need to know a lot about
England to know that doesn't make a lot
of sense um to build a building and then
not have Windows and the question is why
and the answer is that King William III
thought it'd be a good idea to compose a
tax on Windows and his theory and he can
watch Downton Abbey you know it's not a
crazy Theory rich people have to have
more windows
um it's easy to walk around and count
the windows it seemed like a good idea
for attacks but the problem is
it's obvious people don't like paying
taxes and they will engage in crazy
behavior
in order to avoid them which is why the
first principle of sound tax policy is
to have as broad a base as possible and
the problem with having a Water's Edge
regime is you're basically inviting
these multinational corporations to
shift income out right it just violates
the basics of of tax policy not the tax
as broad a base as possible
so next slide um well okay well maybe
it's it's Common Sense policy but won't
all the businesses leave
um important to talk about this um and I
know it's been addressed already but
just to be clear New Hampshire opposes
its business profits tax not based on
physical presence but on economic
activity in the state New Hampshire
currently abortions the business profit
Stacks based on sales not based on
property or payroll in the state and so
there's no real economic thing that a
big multinational taxpayer can do
um to avoid paying these taxes other
than stop making profitable sales in the
state
okay
okay next slide
um is a excerpt from a blog post which
you might have seen from the tax
Foundation talking about what a huge
burden
um worldwide combined reporting would be
and I just wanted to pick apart this
slide just the argument just a little
bit right first of all there's a claim
right that there's a massive increase in
compliance burden but you know uncited
no support
um and the description is well look
here's what you're going to have to do
you're going to have to combine all
these different International Accounting
rules and you're going to have to do it
and bring it into line with how New
Hampshire would do it sounds pretty bad
sounds pretty burdensome
um and on top of that there are all
these other things you're going to have
to keep track of like payroll which you
wouldn't have to do but of course we
just talked about that New Hampshire
uses the sales Factor so actually all
you have to do is keep track of sales
if you go to the next slide I'm going to
try to provide you some evidence such as
there is about compliance costs because
the argument was already made in the
context of the Barclays case that
worldwide component reporting
is burdensome that
argument was subjected to a trial and
actually the Supreme Court in Barclay
who cites the lower courts in California
is finding that the cost was not very
significant right that's the next Slide
the site from Barclays the Supreme Court
you go to the next slide titled also
also explains why that's so the reason
is that the California regulations
permitted reasonable approximations of
foreign income and sales and that those
days the other factors
and didn't require all these sort of
crazy transfer of foreign income
practices um into California practices
the important Point California did give
up mandatory worldwide combined
reporting since I'm in 1987. however
California's new situation is earns new
since 1987 is worldwide combined
reporting is still the default Rule and
corporations can choose a Water's Edge
election
that means these regulations are still
in effect
and that means that many tax
pay particularly taxpayers to have
losses abroad and want to take advantage
of that and will benefit from worldwide
combined reporting have been filing
using the worldwide combined reporting
method continuously over the preceding
decades and has been administered by the
by the franchise tax board and if you go
down this route and I would recommend
having your Department contact the
franchise tax board about how they've
been able to administer the tax and I
will just say because I can't speak
formally about this that they have not
had a lot of difficulty because this is
what what Dan box just told you but but
as for yourself
um
so go to the next slide write more
fundamentally it just doesn't make a lot
of sense
um for these large multinational
corporations to say they just have it's
just too hard to figure out what their
income is or where their sales are
um interestingly and importantly perhaps
if you're really worried about this
compliance issue for purposes of the new
corporate Alternative Minimum Tax the
largest taxpayers are going to have to
use financial statement income including
of their foreign subsidiaries to create
an aggregate picture of the financial
state of the income of the whole group
and so
if the concern is that this would be too
burdensome
um for for smaller taxpayers then just
say if you're subject to the corporate
Alternative Minimum Tax then you're have
to file at a worldwide basis because
you're already doing something very
similar um at the federal level if you
go to the next slide titled really right
that's just again I'm trying to provide
you with evidence here's an example uh
from Amazon's annual report or it's
breaking out sales by geographic
location and that's basically all we
need to know right once we know Amazon
sells in the US
now you can just break it down in terms
of New Hampshire right so it's already
out there
um for as a matter of financial
accounting and compliance with the
Securities laws
um for many of these countries
um again this is just repeating what
Professor um Palestine just talked about
if you go to the rest of the world
um
a couple of points right the notion that
the face erosion is a problem right it's
not just something that um a handful of
people have noticed and perceived um as
a as a problem of both fairness and a
drab
um in some ways on the whole
International economy and tax system
um it's a big issue with the oecd both
pillar one and pillar two
um have worldwide add formulary
components that go to the next slide
um and it makes sense right so if you're
concerned about a big multinational
company pay a 15 minimum tax that's
pillar two then you need to know what's
in the group and what's not in the group
um so that's just worldwide combined
reporting and if you go to the next
slide here is
um an excerpt I'm from the oecd
um rules uh at least current proposed
rules relating to pillar two again
um final
critique that I will address before uh
stopping for questions right again Pull
It in the tax Foundation this is the
slide but there's no money there the
idea is that the itap estimate of 177
million is totally unsound the argument
is that it's unsound because it doesn't
take into account that you have to
reduce New Hampshire's apportional
percentage as well
um
and the the
critique is itself unsound because the
whole premise is that this is income
that's been shifted out and so there's
no reason to dilute the state factors
and taking it into account how much the
state would raise if the income were
added back in it is true if if New
Hampshire goes to worldwide combined
reporting that there would be undilution
of New Hampshire's um factors
um and there would be some winners and
losers and some corporations that have
big losses might pay less than they
currently pay but that's entirely um
appropriate
um and on balance again as
um Dan box explained because of the
significance of income shifting it's
very likely on New Hampshire
um would come out ahead there was a
question raised about the interaction
with guilty
um a federal provision that a limited
slightly different way
um brings back some uh presumed shift to
income it is a good thing that New
Hampshire conforms to guilty
um
the interaction between worldwide
combined important and guilty is is
complicated it probably means that the
amount that New Hampshire would
um gain of is somewhat less than the
current estimates whatever they might be
because New Hampshire is getting some
that income back in its basis in its tax
base through guilty
um it's very hard to say exactly how
much I have you know some you know some
rough intuitions about it that I'd be
happy to talk more about or talk to the
revenue authorities about
um final slide upshots no state has as
much to gain from getting their business
taxation right as New Hampshire
the primary Arguments for worldwide
combiner for the other that's editions
and fair it also turns out that it's
likely to raise revenue but you could
use that Revenue obviously as you want
you could use it to reduce some less
efficient tax you could use it to help
address
um the issue with property tax
Equalization that I know is an issue in
New Hampshire fun sidebar
Texas has something called the margin
tax which is a less good mashup of your
business Enterprise tax and your
business profits tax that everybody
hates why does Texas have this tax it
has this tax to address taxi um property
tax Equalization issues
um so you know just an interesting of
where these things go and then finally I
just wanted to just make myself
available at as things progress I'm
happy to be a resource in the future
about any questions and the final slide
just has some additional sources that
you can refer to
um so that that's it happy to take
questions
excellent thank you very useful slides
the version we have are kind of
microscopic but Jen we'll get these uh
as a computer link so we'll have the
luxury of looking them at them in a
large format at home
they were readable but there were some I
had to really squint at
okay questions
I'll just ask one so if I if I
understand you're saying in effect the
guilty is
effectively like a partial
implementation already in place and
therefore mitigates the potential to
gain but maybe also illustrates where
the potential is
yes that's right I mean it illustrates
that it's a
big problem that the International
Community and the federal government is
dealing with
um it also illustrates that these big
taxpayers are already calculating
um the foreign income of their
subsidiaries for purposes of guilty not
exactly the same calculation clearly
they're already played in the sandbox um
and so it's not a big deal I don't think
I'm reasonably to say uh it'll be it
would
um be overly burdensome and yes in terms
of Revenue estimated something to to
keep in mind I mean I
suspect you're you are making a
reasonable you are drawing a non-trivial
amount of of this income back through
guilty but not at as much as you would
do the worldwide combine the point I
understood um one further question in a
prior slide you referred to one of the
elements of the Supreme Court's Barclay
decision
yeah was that they if I understood this
they took note of the California
regulations use of the term reasonable
approximations and they blessed that
so effectively aren't you essentially
endorsing the idea that any action by
the state of New Hampshire and its
subsequent regulations
would allow for reasonable
approximations that it's
a
a policy choice
that would make the statute more
workable
yes yeah I mean it certainly it's about
a federal constitutional law New
Hampshire has a huge amount of latitude
I think it could probably have something
stricter than California had but
California
had reasonable approximation
it was an issue in the case because the
taxpayers insisted that um the the
worldwide combined reporting was two
burdensome so there was actually
evidence taken about this and this is a
time right where California was also
asking for foreign property and payroll
uh this is and this was obviously a time
when you know Computing was not what it
is today and still the Court's balance
upon actually looking at evidence that
for a big corporation like Barclays it
wasn't such a big deal
um so
I'm not telling New Hampshire exactly
how to approach
um you know I'm combining um with these
foreign corporations I think
um adopting the California approach as
both blessed by the Supreme Court and as
a methodology that clearly works and
that these big businesses are familiar
with how to use in California and will
use when it's to their benefit
representative Schaumburg thank you Mr
chairman
um
what you're saying is that
is it all public or is it all private
so
a professor of accounting um so my
understanding is that
um
this would be for public corporations I
don't that certainly uh to be governed
by fast beyond the SEC I'm
don't want to speculate exactly on how
we work for a private entity although
again it'll be pretty stunning right if
big investors and private entities were
willing to like not get something right
analogous but I don't want to speculate
about that I should have asked my
Two Gentlemen to the left of me
for that question but I was hoping to
get yeah I could do that next Monday
well this is this is just corporate
Alternative Minimum Tax is a barometer
and
um happily I've forgotten the thresholds
for it because my clients are not in
that base but it's only like a couple
hundred companies that are going to be
subject to this as it's been rolled out
um someone else in the crowd may may
know
better on the threshold but it's only
going to apply to a very small subset of
businesses based on billions of book
income based on kind of governed you
know public accounting standards what
yeah that
that's true I can't
see the exact universe but it's a
relatively small number of companies but
the overlap between those companies and
the super normal profits and income
shifting is very very high so someone
would have to do the estimates
um and on that this again I don't think
it's burdens it just means I'm not
necessarily saying that this is
something a compliance person that
smaller companies couldn't handle just
fine but if the concern is that you have
to start somewhere
um and which companies right can most
clearly handle it because they're doing
something similar and which companies
are have the biggest potential to ship
okay all right thank you very very much
I appreciate your patience and waiting
uh waiting your turn
uh so the the commission will take a
yes I I I'm I'm going to basically uh
postpone lunch
um and so we'll proceed Carl uh freedom
I believe is here in the room
thank you for your patience if we're a
couple of minutes past 12 45 I think
we're good okay so we're in recess
briefly
yeah
I'm going to call the commission's
meeting back into session it's uh 12 51.
and I hope everybody got at least an
energy bar or something along those
lines
um
multiple forms of energy including
chocolate
so I'd like to welcome our next
presenter Carl frieden vice president
and general counsel
the Council on state taxation otherwise
like that you want to actually hear me
to start again chairman Spielberg
spilsbury and members of the commission
my name is Carl frieden and vice
president general counsel of the Council
on City Taxation and just by way of a
little bit of background cost is a
non-profit trade Association consisting
of about 500 multi-state corporations
engaged in interstate and international
business you can pretty much think of
you know 500 of the largest thousand
companies in the world
our objective is both education and
advocacy efforts and you know to
preserve and promote what we consider to
be Equitable balanced and
non-discriminatory state and local
taxation a multi-jurisdictional
businesses we generally and this is an
important point we generally don't weigh
in on things like tax rates or how much
how much you want to raise in taxes
those are you know your Sovereign
decisions but we do weigh in on issues
like worldwide combined reporting that
we think are bad tax policy a bad design
as I'll explain both unfair overly
complex and and potentially
discriminatory against
multi-jurisdictional businesses
depending on the way they're done I've
got five slides there that I think will
kind of give our perspective the
business perspective you might say on
why New Hampshire and I'm going to
really focus on New Hampshire there's a
much broader debate around the world
than what the world should do with
multinationals now they should tax them
but why New Hampshire should not adopt
mandatory worldwide combined reporting I
think is the issue in this hearing not
what other states should do or not and
so I'm going to really Zone in on that a
few of the speakers Did drill down on a
couple elements of New Hampshire but I'm
going to go much further to show you
know why your current
tax structure is one that doesn't
require worldwide combined reporting but
as an overview before I get into those
five slides just as I listen today what
I heard was sort of the following from
the three proponents of worldwide
combined reporting one worldwide
combined reporting is constitutional
two there's widespread International
profit shifting by multinational
companies that deprives New Hampshire of
its appropriate share of corporate tax
revenues three worldwide combined
reporting
is the best perhaps the only method for
addressing this and getting the
appropriate foreign Source income into
the New Hampshire business profits tax
base
or worldwide combined reporting is
manageable I think uh Dan Buck said it's
only 900 or a thousand dollars a year to
file for it according to the Barclays
case in five and I think this is a
really important underlying issue here
which is that implicitly this is from
the proponent's perspective
corporations aren't paying their fair
share of taxes in New Hampshire and this
would be one way to address that as well
so let me before I go into my slides
which will I will do sort of quickly but
then and these are leave behinds and and
drill down on some of the points I'm
going to make let me respond
somewhat succinctly to those five points
and then I'll drill down on with a with
with some details there first of all
yeah of course worldwide combined
reporting as long as it's appropriately
structured
um is constitutional Supreme Court said
it twice we have no disagreement there
we do have a disagreement as to just
because something's constitutional
doesn't mean it's the right tax policy
and and I think Dan bucks went quite a
little bit well quite a little overboard
and suggesting almost an endorsement by
the U.S Supreme Court of worldwide
combined reporting what they said in
container in Barclays was it was
constitutional it was a method the
states could use as long as others they
they never endorse it it was the method
or the the fairest method they never
said anything
like that but there's lots of things
that are constitutional that you
wouldn't necessarily want to do you
could double your business profits tax
rate right now that's constitutional but
I'm certainly not suggesting you do that
so that's the first point we agree on
the first point the second point is a
very important one that there's
extensive profit shifting that's
depriving New Hampshire of its revenues
and I'm going to kind of combine the
second point and the third one I'm going
to make and they're certainly there
could be no question that you know I
mean I think the oecd the federal
government with guilty there's a lot of
Nations around the world not just states
that are focused on how to appropriately
tax global companies that have
operations and all over and it's gotten
much more complicated with intangibles
which are easier to move perhaps than
people so there's no question that there
is some level of profit shifting and
it's being dealt with it at a global
basis there's
a huge dispute as to how much and some
of these numbers cited like the 177
million that New Hampshire would somehow
magically get if it could address as
profit shifting or you know in my mind
uh you know incredibly almost
Preposterous numbers and I you know I
could certainly provide you but there
have been a number of critiques of some
of the underlying data suggesting that
some of the data that those numbers are
based off for instance are you know
exaggerated by two-thirds or more but
there is a debate as one of the earlier
speakers said it's it's not exact but
there clearly is profit Shifting the
problem I have with the itep numbers and
they were cited in different forms here
I have a much bigger problem than sort
of the underlying
estimates as to how much profit shifting
there is four percent or ten percent or
thirty percent or whatever the bigger
problem is I tip in all of its numbers
doesn't take into account what a state
is currently doing in terms of taxing
foreign Source income so the assumption
and the itep numbers is that they're not
taxing foreign Source income and all of
this would come in and that's a
particularly misleading Notions
especially given New Hampshire and when
I get to it in a minute in the slides
New Hampshire currently is taxing most
or All Foreign Source income New
Hampshire is taxing more foreign Source
income right now than any other state
other than Vermont and I'll go into this
in a little more detail it's taxing more
foreign Source income than the federal
government and even though it's a little
bit of an Apple's an oranges comparison
arguably it's taxing more foreign Source
income than any government in the world
right now is taxing of its
multinationals so somehow this notion
that you get 177 million dollars because
you're not taxing foreign Source income
ignores a very silly in fact which is
you actually have most if not all and
it's you know it depends on the company
but most if not all on either a current
or deferred basis of the foreign income
in your tax base so you you don't need
to do this at all if that's your concern
if there's some huge tax cap I'll also
comment you know briefly on the the
complexity of it and you know there's no
question that companies can
do worldwide some of them is one of the
speakers mentioned are doing it on an
elective basis it was done in the past
you know for 20 or 30 or 40 years it's
not that they can't do it but it is
quite a bit more complicated and I'll
I'll provide a little bit overview of
that and then the final point I'm going
to make which is I think a really
important one for New Hampshire is
ultimately behind all of this is that
business is not paying their fair share
and it's really interesting and um I
didn't submit it yet but I will send in
there's a study that Ernst young does
for cost every year which is called
total state and local business taxes it
has estimates for each state on how you
compare to the other states and just
some quick ones here which I think show
that business is paying more than their
fair share of taxes compared to other
states and this is because of your
unique stack structure I mean you don't
have a sales tax you don't have a
personal income tax so it's not
surprising you're collecting more from
business but if you just want to look at
the overall staff that's
on a national average business pays
about
43.7 percent of all state local taxes in
New Hampshire it's 47.9 percent and I
you know I'll send this report to you
but much more importantly for your
purposes because you're concerned with
state taxes
at the state level the difference is
even greater New Hampshire is the third
highest proportion of all their state
taxes it comes from business 62.7
percent compared to a national average
of 37.8 percent the only two states
higher than you are Alaska and Wyoming
which are heavily dependent upon oil
revenues not surprisingly and and it's
again because of the importance of the
business profit tax and the business
Enterprise the the taxis shouldn't be
surprising but they're still relevant
and that's collecting from both small
and big business but business pays a
very large share of the tax base already
in New Hampshire much larger certainly
at the state level than almost any other
state and if you break it down by you
know your number one in terms of a
corporate excise tax as a percentage of
overall taxes you know your business
profit Stacks or as a percentage of just
taxes a business pays you're number one
in the country on both of them so this
is not a tax my point being that
compared to other states you're under
utilizing your if anything over
utilizing it so let me just get into the
charts here because I want to drill down
on a couple of those points and then I'd
love to entertain questions and I'll try
to respond to there were just so many
different comments made
I can't possibly respond to them all but
let me try to respond to the ones I
think are more important
this is a chart
of which states tax the two major
sources of foreign income taxed by
States now are guilty rough Justice you
can think of it as something the federal
government started doing in 2018 it's
taxing on a current basis 50 percent in
some states much less than others but
it's it's sort of like roughly 50
percent of all of your Global income
less uh an amount that allows you a
return on investment and you know it
could go into the formula if you want
but basically for a lot of companies
it's fifty percent of their Global
income is what's in the New Hampshire
tax base and what's in what's in the
federal tax base that's one method of
taxing foreign income that just started
four or five years ago New Hampshire is
following the federal method of taxing
50 percent of that New Hampshire also
taxes a hundred percent of subpartaf
which is another
thing the federal government does which
is a smaller category of a sort of a
passive type of income earned abroad but
really importantly the federal
government for 90 years used to tax a
hundred percent of foreign dividends so
they would tax All Foreign income
less what was taxed abroad but on a
deferred basis only when you dividended
it back they stopped doing that in 2017.
New Hampshire is one of only three
states that taxes that at 50 or above
Vermont and New Hampshire and Vermont
New Hampshire tax at 100 percent and uh
Minnesota at 50 percent so just uh you
know to sum up the bidding here you've
got a state that's now taxing roughly 50
percent
between subpart F and guilty roughly 50
percent of foreign income on a current
basis less you know a certain amount for
some companies as a return on investment
and then what you don't tax
most if not all of that comes in later
when you tax the dividends that get
distributed back now in the past the
dividends didn't necessarily used to get
distributed back as there was a federal
tax on those dividends and companies
kind of held on to it now there's much
less incentive because the federal
government doesn't tax that anymore so
that's why New Hampshire's taxing more
now than the federal government because
you're using their own old system of
taxing 100 percent of
you know residual foreign income when it
gets distributed shareholders and your
taxing fifty percent of support F and 50
percent are guilty when you look at this
chart the companies in La the the states
in light blue
which is a majority of the states don't
tax any foreign Source income and that's
some of the largest states in the
country now you can question their
decision or not they're certainly aware
of all these discussions that we're
having today on you know profit shifting
and all that but more than half the
states don't tax any foreign Source
income a smattering of the state's tax
20 or 30 percent of guilty California
has a special method where they tax 25
percent of foreign dividends but none of
guilty Minnesota now is a new state that
sort of taxes 50 percent of foreign
dividends and fifty percent of dividend
of guilty but basically Vermont and New
Hampshire are alone among all the states
in taxing as much foreign income as
you're talking about so when you talk
about profit shifting and this is where
this all comes together
purpose of worldwide combined reporting
is on the premise that there's a lot of
profit shifting and the only way you can
accurately measure how much New
Hampshire should get is its fair share
is to bring in that foreign income my
point here is that either on a current
or a deferred basis New Hampshire is
bringing in most for many companies all
of that foreign income and certainly
more than any other state and certainly
more than the federal government so this
so-called tax Gap here that needs to be
addressed by worldwide combined
reporting if any state didn't need to do
something about it
it's your state and and you know and you
know it's discreditary chansky mentioned
that a little bit although he just
mentioned guilty in the chair had a good
question on that but the full scope of
what you're taxing and the reason being
is that even when you dropped worldwide
combined reporting in 1986 you
immediately started taxing 100 of
foreign dividends which is what the
federal government had been doing
historically and which very few States
ever did I mean even back then very few
States ever followed the federal model
so it's not as if you ever sort of
ignored this even when you transitioned
in 86 from uh worldwide to Water's Edge
you still have been since that day
taxing 100 of foreign dividends in 2019
effective for 2020 you added in guilty
without taking away as all the other
states pretty much except for one did
when they got rid of foreign dividend
you know when they got guilty they got
rid of the foreign dividends so you're
taxing it two different ways and that
it's nothing unconstitutional about that
it's just you're covering it two
different ways when you know almost no
one else is so that's kind of the
importance of that chart is it doesn't
mean that
you know you couldn't or shouldn't
consider worldwide but it does mean that
the problem that is
um is all the proponents keep saying you
need worldwide combined reporting from
all this profit shifting and all this
these big guys getting away with stuff
that they're not paying their fair share
in New Hampshire doesn't
hold up to the facts that you are
actually including right now in your tax
base either on a current or deferred
basis most if not all of this foreign
Source income
just quickly on this one you've all
heard you know the the issues on Water's
Edge versus uh separate reporting versus
worldwide and and there there's only one
state that partially taxes worldwide
right now and that's Alaska for oil and
gas as you can see from this map all the
blue States I think some of them said
the number 27 do Water's Edge and again
it's been pointed out just because
nobody else does it
doesn't mean that you shouldn't do it
but given that you're already taxing a
lot of the if not all of the income
that's subject to contention here uh to
move to a whole other system that nobody
else is doing it and I might add you
know and there it would would take a
much longer discussion but the comments
that Dan bucks and Darian made about
the rest of the world is looking at
things like worldwide apportionment it's
certainly true the rest of the world is
looking at ways of having global minimum
taxes in pillar 2 and in guilty the U.S
started this whole thing that are
different than the prior methods and
that vary from arm's length but that
doesn't mean they're the same as
worldwide and just to give you an
example of the European Union is more
seriously than ever considering having
formulary apportionment but they're
considering having it for a Water's Edge
for the European Union they're not
talking about doing worldwide so again
even though there's lots of Concepts and
Global taxation is Shifting doesn't mean
that they're moving in the direction of
what the states would do with Worldwide
combined reporting and the other thing I
should point out is that all of these
measures that are being considered by
the eoecd or by the federal governments
around the world in terms of having
global minimum taxes and I'd be glad to
answer questions I'm quite familiar with
what they're proposing all are being
done at the national level there's not a
single sub-national government other
than the US in the world that's really
approaching these with a minor exception
I mentioned in my slides of Korea taxes
a little bit of foreign Source income at
the sub-national level but these issues
are all being addressed because they're
quite complex
at the national level and that's not
because these countries don't have
sub-national governments a lot of them
don't but about 20 percent of the oecd
G20 Nations have sub-national income
taxes Germany Canada and so forth
they're not doing this sub-national
level so you know in my mind the there
is a problem here in terms of
modernizing the world's
taxing system in an income taxing system
to address the ability to in the
complexity of Supply chains and Global
growth and global trade but it's all at
the national level it's a sub-national
level and there's there's a reason for
that because it's complicated and
because if in the U.S and
um I can send you my article I wrote on
this if in the U.S the U.S does it at
the national level and the sub-national
level we're going to be taxing arguably
our multinationals more than other
countries will who are only just taxing
it at the national levels one other
point I wanted to make out on guilty is
I talked about guilty being 50 percent
roughly
that's true but in 2026 at the federal
level it's going to go up to and New
Hampshire would conform it would go up
to 62.5 percent so all of a sudden 62.5
percent of
the current income or the current income
less you know return on investment would
be taxed federally and in New Hampshire
without you doing anything so again this
is not an issue that's being ignored by
New Hampshire just a couple points
on the administrative burden issue and
again be glad to answer questions but
you know it's certainly true and you
know the other speakers you know
there's no denying that lots of States
had worldwide for a number of years so
clearly companies had to comply with it
states had to administer it it's
certainly true that some companies
choose where they can because there's
elective worldwide they choose you know
obviously probably when they have Global
losses or Global profits that are less
than their domestic ones they choose
worldwide and they go through the
administrative headache of that it's not
true that it's just a 900 or a thousand
dollar return you know we've talked to
lots of our members about how burdensome
if it is and I'll just give you one
example and this is really pertinent to
New Hampshire
it's certainly true that you tax guilty
and foreign dividends now right subpart
F so you might say well wait a minute
you've already got all this Global
income in your tax base don't you
already have all these complexities
and the answer is no and the reason it's
no is because guilty in foreign
dividends and subpart all F all of those
figures have to be calculated for
federal purposes they're on the 5471 or
some other return so it's not that you
don't have to come up with some
adjustments and apportionment for those
but they're already on the federal
return if you go to worldwide
worldwide you know that you do have to
and it's not like you have to file a
return for your 100 subsidiaries around
the world but you do have to look at
your worldwide book income you do have
to look at adjustments that have to be
made just like you make adjustments now
for New Hampshire versus Federal you'd
have to do the same thing for worldwide
it is harder to do because there's
different Accounting Standards you have
different depreciation you treat
Partnerships differently than most the
world does so there are a number of
adjustments that have to be made and
make that a much more complicated and
again not impossible not something that
companies couldn't do or States couldn't
administer but quite a bit more
difficult and much more expensive than
the current system where you're pulling
in a lot of foreign Source income based
on numbers that are available or largely
available for federal purposes and the
point of this slide is it's not just a
problem for the companies it's a problem
for the Department you have to audit
this stuff and you're a small state and
so you will have to unless you want to
just accept the numbers come up with
Auditors who understand some of the
differences that I was talking about and
potentially understand differences
between IFRS
excuse me in gaap which are
International Accounting rules in in U.S
counting rules certainly differences you
have in your tax base and deductions and
the way you treat flow through entities
for for New Hampshire versus the rest of
the world and so again I'm just like I
did with
worldwide combined reporting I'm not
suggesting at all that you can't do that
you certainly can it's constitutional
it's not that people couldn't eventually
comply with this but it's way harder
than your current system whereas I
pointed out you're already taxing
most if not all foreign Source income
final point I wanted to make was just to
sum up some of the other points on the
on the on the policy concern so you know
all things being equal compared to what
you're doing now and you know I'm not
endorsing necessarily what you're doing
now I mean most businesses would say
you're taxing way more foreign Source
income than you should but given that
you are the administrative complexity of
switching to worldwide combined
reporting instead of doing it the way
you are it is significant there is and
you may or may not care about being a
policy outlier but you know if you did
worldwide combine reporting
you would be the first state to do it at
least in the last 30 or 35 years
you'd be the only state to do it right
now other than Alaska for for the oil
and gas industry uh in some other states
on an elective basis the federal
government doesn't do it there are some
overlapping concepts with what's going
on and extremely if you read about
pillar one and pillar two it's extremely
complicated what they're trying to do
but they are doing it the national level
and they aren't going all the way to
combine reporting they have more minimum
tax structures you know if a low tax
countries not taxing something we're
going to tax it up to 15 percent but
again they're all based on either
forcing the low tax country to raise
their rates or get rid of some of their
credits incentives or having the home
country of the multinational
tax the stuff the tax burden I addressed
before I just have one of the stats
there but there's some worse ones in the
sense of you know if you think business
should pay more in New Hampshire which
is you know you don't have to be at the
national averages or whatever but you
know certainly I think that our annual
study shows that because of your unique
tax structure business is paying
particularly at the state level
significantly more of all taxes than
they do in Most states and that's you
know that's appropriate from your
perspective but again I don't think you
have to add on to that but a new tax
system that imposes even potentially
more burden and then the revenue
estimate in either Department of Revenue
could talk to this but
some of these numbers like these
suggestions that you would just get this
you know fantasy 177 million dollars
quoted by several of the speakers uh you
know they don't back away from the
number but you know the number does not
take into account
let alone critiques of you know whether
the the under underlying numbers are
valid or not or overstated to start with
but far more important doesn't take into
account what you're taxing Darian
brought something else up which it
doesn't take into account apportionment
it's not adding the foreign factors
which you really would have to add in
but even more important than that it is
it doesn't take account that New
Hampshire is already taxing most if not
all of this income so that's
the the general presentation I did want
to make one point on there was some
conflation early on and one of the
speakers talking about foreign parented
companies versus domestic and you know
all of these numbers like 170 million
seven million dollars those aren't
numbers about profit losses from foreign
parented companies those are you know
U.S parenting companies the reason for
that is because pretty much under the
international regime right now each
country can tax if it wanted to on a
worldwide basis its own multinationals
they don't tax other countries
multinationals so uh you know I think
it's a little bit of red herring there
are certainly different rules for
foreign parented companies but that's
not
by any means the big issue here the big
issue is U.S parented companies and
should you be imposing worldwide
combined reporting on them in addition
you could consider imposing it on
foreign companies which do have certain
different rules but that's you know I
for me that's sort of a side issue and
that's certainly not the issue that's
being addressed with the estimates on
profit shifting that has nothing to do
with foreign parented countries the
companies so let me stop there I would
love to you know on any of these topics
and you know if anybody has any
questions on what's going on with other
one or pillar two and why that's
different than worldwide combined
reporting I'd be glad to answer that
there's there's a lot there but I I do
think that this issue has to be
considered not where whether any state
should do it I I I don't think they
should but certainly the issue here is
whether New Hampshire should do
worldwide combined reporting and in my
thank you very much
the pre-presentation I appreciated but
I've got uh a couple three four
questions here
um
you talked about the percent of Taxation
in New Hampshire uh can you provide us
with the daily source of that uh
yeah so it's it's from this report which
is based on Federal and state-specific
data so
Ernst young has an economic policy unit
in to my knowledge nobody's ever
criticized their underlying numbers I
mean you might say well this is not
relevant or you know there's an
explanation for it but it's all based on
Federal and State data if you could
provide that too yeah no I will send
tonight I'll just send the whole report
and we do it once a year so if you went
to our website you could see the
information for the last 20 years it's
it's very informative I mean our our
discussion aside all right I just went
to your website and it's not you have to
log in and all that stuff well no this
this information is available for the
public so if you just go to the it's
there's some things you have to log in
for but all of our studies are publicly
available
do that at home from PC
um you also talked about the fact that
they're sub-national uh in the United
States is generally called federalism uh
other places uh uh can as with the
different provinces have a little
slightly different and Germany is based
on the Kingdom so it's slightly
different Austria same thing for
Australia with the different states they
have down there but uh so the question
is would worldwide uh combined reporting
contribute to
um the concept of federalism in the
United States under the 10th Amendment
reserving rights or would it be
detrimental to federalism in a
philosophical sense and that yes or no
is a good enough answer
I don't know if I can answer yes or no I
mean it's it's a it's a constitutionally
sanctioned by the Supreme Court
methodology whether it contributes or
not is in the eye of the beholder
it's kind of the question the answer I
was expecting hoping for actually uh if
I might Mr chair a couple more yes go
ahead
you also mentioned following up on that
uh sub-national taxation
if a sub-national entity goes to
combined reporting
and a sub-national entity or even a
nation over there wherever over there is
goes to combined reporting and yet
they're based basing their taxation on
the same Corpus
so we're getting our cut
they're getting their cut on the same
dollar
so isn't this double triple quadruple
potentially absolutely in the Supreme
Court kind of said if you read container
Barclay that there could be some double
or triple taxation but that's not the
point the point is if everybody did this
method it would work out okay and I'll
give you a great example of that one of
the objections the business Community
has to guilty really is that for federal
purposes you calculate a guilty amount
and then you deduct foreign tax credits
you deduct what was paid abroad right
you're not trying to double tax
something for State purposes you don't
do that because we don't observe foreign
tax credits so you bring in guilty and
then you apportion it and that may or
may not be a rough justice so there's a
lot of that going on and there's a lot
of risk of that coming up with global
tax reform
yeah that there's a whole bunch of
questions that just came to mind on that
which well
we may come back to you well no I got
one more question on that okay we talked
about earlier
um and
just from your perspective because we
I've asked this question of other
individuals other presenters as well
um
the the data on Revenue
uh pre-19 or 1981 1986 versus after
1986. it's my understanding that the
business Revenue not just from New
Hampshire but
globally has increased with the going
away from
a combined reporting versus
the percentage or the the basis that was
there
at that time do you have any data on
that
I I don't I mean I haven't seen a study
that's that's looked conclusively at
that not not that it doesn't exist but I
would mention one thing you brought up
the question to several other
speakers
um on what about if you have losses and
there's an interesting question because
it's a valid you know I mean I think
overall you're going to have more gains
and losses so you know but you know the
losses are reflected and you could
actually lose money from different
companies with combined reporting but
you know with Worldwide combined
reporting what's interesting though is
guilty and foreign Dividends are only
positive numbers you don't nor does the
federal government allow foreign losses
to come into the calculation they you
know that they may reduce a given Year's
guilty but you don't get a negative
number that carries over so the way
you're doing it right now is only
pulling in positive Revenue you're not
pulling in losses from abroad but given
your current system a taxing foreign
Source income
yeah but at the same time that positive
member can be reduced by the expenses
it can be reduced by losses and the
foreign dividend number can't because
that's only a positive number it can be
reduced in a given year but let's say a
company has 100 million dollar loss that
it's a current year number that gets
lost that doesn't come over to New
Hampshire wow you're essentially seeing
there's no carry forward there's no
carry forward on on guilty it doesn't
work that way yeah so that you know
well that would let's do do the ship
building because like if we're coming up
with a new let's say uh that company is
coming up with the new ship building
design in Norway at one of their yards
but they need money
because Norway's not financing it
uh because it's going to be a commercial
ship or something like that super
fantastic green ship
um
they're going to need money from
somewhere to finance that so they're
going to take it from everywhere they
can to in order to do that that's just
shifting profits from here to there to
pay for something else yeah and I mean
that would be over a period of time yeah
I mean there's a this is this is a you
know it's a little esoteric but the big
one of the biggest difference one of the
biggest differences between pillar 2 and
guilty is pillar two is a country by
country calculation so they don't take
in account losses in other countries
guilty as a net calculation but there
isn't carryover losses as you said so
you know it's not it doesn't mean you'll
get more or less out of worldwide
combined reporting but it is a
difference you're not pulling in sort of
net losses from foreign operations right
now into your tax system thank you for
providing more questions thank you my
pleasure
one question I'd like to ask so we have
some states apparently that offer an
option
and I have to presume that that option
is always evaluated in the sense of
which methodology results in the lower
tax bill
so
based on your experience what's the
rationale of those States
that say you can if it works better for
you file unitary combined reporting but
you can also limit it the water's edge
if you want well I'm thinking that yeah
I mean one qualification and what you
just said is most the states that allow
the option I think there's like 10 or 8
or something require you to do it for a
number of years so it's not like you can
go back and forth so you know it does
give them you know maybe they think it's
it's fair I mean if you if you have
on a continuous basis less profitable or
losing operations abroad than you do in
your us it's you know it's a might be
perceived as a fair way of income
averaging but a lot of it binds you for
it for a number of years so I guess you
know I I can't answer specifically your
question some of it may just be a
carryover those are mostly the same
States that had it before and they
either left it as the default like
California and then you can opt into the
water's edge that's what happened with a
lot of them it just they didn't get rid
of it from their system they just gave
you the water's edge option
that one leaves me curious to dig
further but thank you yeah
I also wanted to clarify so I've seen
the state by state report in the past
it's very helpful and I understand the
the basis for your
uh indication that New Hampshire
raises 47.9 obvious state and local
taxes
through the business taxes
compared to 43.6 which is not such a
drastic difference
to say something else and I'm not sure I
picked up on what you were you mentioned
something else about there being
62.7 percent of New Hampshire's revenue
from business so we break the 37 average
and I didn't get the distinction it's a
great question so and there's just a
separate chart in there that you'll see
but we break it down the first
statistics you mentioned was what
portion of all state and local local
includes property tax which changes that
number significantly but the other stat
we break it down what percent of state
taxes come from business what percentage
of local taxes come from businesses
inclusion or exclusion of the local real
property tax is the difference yeah yeah
I mean
absolutely and and since you're you may
affect property tax policy but you're
more concerned with raising state taxes
that that's why I brought up that number
was 62 percent versus just like 37 I
mean you really raise a lot from
business I'm not saying it's good or bad
it's just the way your tax policies work
out
so a further question just to clarify on
the foreign dividend taxes as I
understand and I'm not sure if it was
tied this closely but you said that at
the time that New Hampshire
repealed the combined unitary reporting
that's when we implemented the tax on
foreign dividends were they tied yeah
yeah I mean I don't know if before 19
well before 1981 you had probably had
separate accounting so yeah at the time
it happened and to New Hampshire's great
credit at the time that the great Stan
Arnold you know I remember your great
commissioner who was you know beloved on
both the private and the public side of
it but he did he was one of the only two
or three states that not you know as a
legislature you decided to tax 100
percent of foreign dividends which was
what the federal government had been
doing for like 90 years but you also
then brought in all the factors you did
it fairly you said okay we're going to
tax 100 of global income when that
income comes in we're going to allow
those horn factors to come in
um
Professor hellerstein's wrote ridden
extensively on that is the fair way
bringing the income bringing the factors
Most states didn't and continue not to
do that they don't bring in all the
factors so actually when you did it you
thought it through better than most
States and allowed you to bring in the
income and bring in the factors so and
so further to clarify when we say
foreign dividends I'm not familiar with
that provision in the tax code
we're talking about
it may include dividends received by
individual shareholders who are private
individuals but we're talking primarily
about dividending between Affiliated
corporate entities yeah so just to
clarify so just give an example
individual taxes are much different and
you know so I'm not you know getting to
that and I know you don't have a
personal income tax but if you had 50
U.S
subsidiaries for U.S parented company
and 50 foreign ones foreign Dividends
are simply all of the income earned by
those foreign subsidiaries you don't tax
it on a current basis and that now you
and the Federal Government taxes a big
chunk of it on under guilty but the rest
of it you don't tax unless they send it
back to the parent so it's getting
rolled up dividended back so it means it
eventually gets taxed there was a big
problem internationally which is one of
the reasons the U.S changed it because
three trillion dollars was sitting there
because what was the incentive to bring
it back all I was pointing out was for
the handful of states that do still tax
dividends probably much less of a
disincentive to bring it back now so
you're probably getting more money from
it because you're not getting federally
taxed on anymore because the federal
government got rid of that tax phased it
out no longer a reason to just pack it
in a foreign country correct and so that
even though that might not have brought
you in as much money between 86 and
yes sir
all right thank you representative
thank you
Mr frieden and I have crossed paths
before and here back in 2020 and
February and uh
I hope it was amicable but yeah well
we've
I pulled out some papers that I had from
back then but
my new questions now good you mentioned
that
New Hampshire businesses
multinationals
are really paying more than their fair
share but
are there businesses in New Hampshire
that profit shift to reduce liability
here in this state
well my point was and I don't know if I
said penguin for sure I was just
comparing you to other states so it's
you know someone could they can decide
or not but the point I was making was it
certainly profits everything exists as
you heard from other speakers certainly
the whole world has recognized it
there's a big debate as to how much but
that doesn't mean it doesn't exist but
the solution to profit shifting
being proposed is to bring the foreign
Source income into the base one way to
do that is being proposed which is a you
know we we think overly complicated and
different than anyone else does which is
worldwide combined reporting another way
to bring it in whether it's profit
shifting or not but when you bring in
guilty when you bring in foreign
dividends you're bringing in the profit
shifted foreign income the non-profit
children you're bringing in all the
global income or most of it and so it's
sort of one in the same if you were to
say to me that there's some you know
there's five multinationals in New
Hampshire and three of them are profit
shifting and two of them aren't when you
tax their foreign Source income you
don't really distinguish guilty
distinguishes a little foreign dividends
doesn't distinguish at all right it's
just bringing in all of the money earned
abroad eventually and that's whether it
was low taxed High tax whatever you're
not really making a distinction between
those I mean guilty tries to make a
distinction very imperfectly foreign
dividends doesn't make a distinction
right so
does that does it answer your question
yeah
financer
uh I had another question here
do you have historically do you remember
because you and I were both young way
back in this time period in 2020. well
I'm going back to 1984 right now
do you have any idea why it was so
important 1984 or 8586 to change
from our
worldwide combined reporting slash
uh unitary methods that we had then to
go to Water's Edge any anything
Insight that you can give us well I do
remember in 84 and 86 the Celtics won
the title right those are those are
important the years for Larry Bird as
well as 81 as well as 81.
and I could give you all their numbers
too but
um no I mean there's just been a lot
written on that topic I mean clearly
there was a Supreme Court decision that
said you could do it and then there was
both some foreign countries many many it
wasn't just a banner UK that were upset
with that and then there was a Reagan
Reagan presidency who through the
secretary Reagan had a commission and
the commission came up with conclusions
that said you shouldn't do Water's Edge
and even backed it up a little bit by
saying that if you don't voluntarily
move away we'll consider Federal
legislation to do it so that was sort of
it's been well written about that that
was the sequence of events that occurred
at that time
uh well in your comment that they would
have done Federal legislation I think
Professor hellerstein might disagree
with that that New Hampshire can set its
own tax policies
various things well you know the states
have the states have right but the
federal government has I'm not saying
they would ever should have but they
have the right under the Commerce Clause
not the negative Commerce Clause but the
positive Commerce Clause to decide that
something is a violation of Commerce if
and they could decide that that was a
violation of Commerce to do it but they
didn't but they could have
uh
Professor hellerstein make a comment
he's back he's he's been itching he's
yes
I can't resist this it's neither neither
good nor bad but I just think we all
there's something when you I if if
tomorrow
New Hampshire decides to have an income
tax
with
one factor
two factors three factors that's up to
New Hampshire
and the only test as to whether or not I
don't think I like this I'm just telling
you this is
ought to be on the table is whether it
is internally consistent in other words
the test for the validity of a a new
formula a new is if every state did what
New Hampshire is doing not that they do
would it result in double taxation if
the answer is no it's okay by contrast
when you think about it and this is
terrible I think not terrible is not
good I mean uh for many years Iowa
every state had three factors it makes
sense what produces income right Capital
they told us way back then and labor
and sales that's okay Market
and then Iowa decided Well you know we
think it's just sales
how can you do that you don't count
Capital you don't count labor the U.S
Supreme Court said you know
it's okay they basically say
there still is the question as to
whether or not Iowa may have taxed too
much but I'm just saying when you
evaluate this there's in effect the
general constitutional test is just
whether if everybody else did it
would it hurt cross-border taxation if
the answer is no
uh then that means the basic approach is
okay then you still have what keeps us
in business people building better it
turns out that when you look at the
actual facts of the case when Iowa
assigns all of the income of General
Motors just on the number of the cars
that were purchased in Iowa that's
disproportionate so I just think that
ought to be something you consider when
you're thinking about this issue that
what may be bad in application may not
be bad in terms of anybody thinking
about is this
okay is there anything that you'd like
to add well no just I mean you know ice
my first part of my discussion or
dialogue was just this is constitutional
that's different from whether it's good
tax policy for New Hampshire and that's
kind of what I focused on I think more
than most of the speakers who were kind
of more generically talking about this
is good tax policy I mean I think you
have to look at it not just is this you
know generically good tax policy for all
states but is it good tax policy for New
Hampshire given that you at least in my
mind have already largely maybe more
than you should have but largely
addressed this issue already in terms of
foreign Source income being in your
income tax base I would just add a
further comment on the Constitutional
issues so
the question of the Commerce Clause has
been litigated in these cases and the
Supreme Court has blessed what the
states were doing given them latitude
fair and reasonable
the thing that it's never really cropped
up but seemed threatening at various
junctures was whether the federal
Congress would act because of the
federal if the federal Congress did
um
take the step
of regulating this area and dictating a
particular system that would probably
constitute preemption
and what I recall of the period of 1983
to 86 is that Congress was being urged
to act and never took the bait
so that just further amplifies that it's
a matter of public policy the states are
free to do it and Congress has resisted
the temptation to Tire hands
and I I mean no part of my discussion
did I suggest that Congress would step
in now or in the times have changed a
lot States could certainly
do this the question is is it a
good idea or not to do it I think that's
what we're all you know and I think
you've had a terrific discussion on that
today
well we have and thank you and I had one
more oh one more okay I still have the
uh
when you were here we talked uh Jason
Furman was the professor at uh
practice of economic policy at Harvard
presentation to uh Congress
the corporate tax collections are very
low in historical perspective and
compared with other countries
this contributes to overall low level of
Revenue
and
I'm concerned like with people like Mr
Collins over here the private domestic
company
that
in this country we have no privileged
class either citizens or business
Arrangements
do you feel that
this bill is structured it really opens
up and my feeling to fairness and
equality to all everywhere
in New Hampshire business structures
or if this bill fails in this Commission
does it give continued power to a
privileged class of businesses
multinationals uh over our domestic
businesses
just I mean I'm impressed you had notes
from that I'll be careful what I say to
you in the future
2020 whenever it was no I mean I think
you know I'm I'm
looking at this from the purpose of this
commission which is determining whether
New Hampshire should do this or not and
I don't think everyone's looking to New
Hampshire as the beacon of if they go
this way or that way it will change
everything so I can't answer your
broader question but I do think it's
really important and that was if
anything that was my major point in my
presentation with my first substantive
slide second slide in there is that all
that you're doing with Worldwide and
it's a lot is bringing is suggesting
that you can't determine how much is
earned in New Hampshire unless you bring
in the global income and the global
factors of a company that's all
worldwide does right you take away the
fancy name whereas with Water's Edge
you're just looking at all the income in
the U.S by the U.S subsidiaries
and if you are doing that already you're
largely it's not 100 match but if you're
largely doing that already in a
different way
by you know with your taxation of guilty
subpart F and foreign dividends
you know for me that puts the whole
question of profit shifting to the side
how much it is is it you know because
you're already addressing the issue in a
different way and so the choice New
Hampshire is even though you're
addressing it in bringing in more
foreign
the federal government but perhaps the
way even other countries are thinking
about doing under pillar too
it's a little bit different but arguably
you're you're bringing in more foreign
Source income than they're even thinking
of doing
do you need to go some other methodology
to do it now it might be a different
question I'm sure we'll have different
debates in lots of other states but
okay thank you second one clarification
so therefore it's fair to impute that
you believe that if New Hampshire was to
implement
unitary combined reporting then it would
be appropriate at that time
to do away with the taxation foreign
dividends and guilty well you'd have to
I mean not just appropriate it would be
double taxation if you didn't yeah you'd
have to deal away with them and and you
know we're you know it's just like the
US has credits for you know to make sure
they don't double tax stuff but yeah you
couldn't do
both and you know my point among other
points was to switch not only is more
administratively complex but there are
consequences to do something that nobody
else is doing you know both you know
Optics of it and and the you know the
the breadth of what you're trying to do
as well as the complexity so personally
I'm saying you shouldn't go in that
direction exactly as I understood you
then thank you thank you
okay
um
so that brings us to our last presenters
um and uh I'm we're calling forward Fred
cool broth director of audit division at
dra and Kian Wong one of our members who
of course is tax policy council at the
dra
and um I think this has been a very
balanced
agenda and I'm extremely pleased with
the fact that we've had you know robust
proponents and opponents and and good
reasons
the question that I think we really want
to focus on now with the dra is as a
practical matter if we assume that we
actually enact this program for example
on representative Schamberg's hb121
what would you be dealing with
in terms of forms filings audits
enforcement and the like
so take it away sure and as you said
this is Fred cool broth director of
audit with my colleague King Wong
text YC Council the dra before we start
we just want to state that the dra does
not have a position on this we take the
easy Road out
and um thanks everybody for bearing with
us here I know we've technically we're
in at like negative two minutes
according to the agenda so apologies for
that and uh I just want to say as a as a
student of tax and a self-professed tax
nerd this has just been a pleasure for
just speaking for myself this has been a
pleasure I'm sure for Keen as well just
to hear all these experts who are a lot
smarter than me talk about these topics
it's believe it or not this is fun for
me it's why I'm in the world of tax so
this has been a pleasure and I
appreciate the commission's time and
given us an opportunity an opportunity
to chat here
um we can certainly
um talk through the the Practical
implications for Dra here and but we
could also get a little bit into the
substance as well but I think everyone
did a really good job with that already
so we could sort of play that by year
and see what the commission's appetite
and what the time allows for
to to your point chairman
um
as a practical matter there would just
be more of everything I like to say
um the there certainly would be more
demand placed onto the uh our so-called
front-end operations so the
um
the division of our department that
handles tax returns there would just be
more tax returns both from the existing
combined filing groups that would just
have more entities in their group
there's just going to be more paper but
also potentially new taxpayers so
they'll just be a greater volume of tax
returns to process
that is something the department can can
swallow and and administer so that's
certainly not something that we couldn't
administer
from an audit perspective the demands
would be greater
um as I said there would be more of
everything all the much more in the way
of documents
um from a practical matter
the logistical strain would be
significant we'd be looking at
additional expenses particularly for
travel
um the method of auditing
these types of taxpayers involves field
work so we have to go to their
headquarters or if not their
headquarters at least where we can
reasonably expect a material amount of
their documentation and their responsive
folks to be
normally under a water's edge method
that's or always under a wide water's
edge method that's somewhere within
within the United States
if we move to a worldwide methodology
the only way to enforce this is to go to
where the documents and where the people
are so travel would involve going to
Japan or China or India
um
that's going to bring with it obviously
the increased cost and and burden of
travel
as some folks already elaborated on
there will be some language issues at
play here because uh
that as uh folks have mentioned Ronald
Reagan a couple of times that the thing
we'll borrow from an audit perspective
there is the whole Credo of trust but
verify we're going to need to see Source
documentation from taxpayers so that
involves seeing what they have prepared
in the original language and you know
we're lucky to have Keane who is smarter
than me and speak several languages but
that is a practical reality that we
would be looking at we would need
um to draw down on foreign language
expertise either as part of hiring or
Outsourcing that function to some kind
of service provider
and then as folks have already mentioned
there are accounting and
um currency exchange exchange rates and
processing issues that we would just
have to take into account as a part of
that that just increase the complexity
of the audit process
so it it is more complicated I think if
this is
or I know if this is something that the
legislature decides to do it just will
be more of a
um of a burden on audit or it would be
it would demand more resources from
audit to give you a current sense for
what this looks like we have several
different teams uh in the audit division
the one that's currently the team that
currently audits these types of
taxpayers the large multinationals that
are filing on a Water's Edge basis right
now that we have about 14 or exactly 14
of those positions that are fortunately
fully funded thank you all
um not including their manager so we can
kick that up to 15. right now I'm at a
vacancy of uh like a third so I I miss I
have five vacant positions right now and
that will go up to
want an additional vacant position for a
total of six when one of our best
Auditors retires Friday so it's it's a
an existing strain on our resources as
many of you know
um this is a difficult hiring
environment for employers and I'm an
employer in a sense I I go out into the
market and I hire accountants and
lawyers
who go out into the world and audit
these taxpayers and it can be a
challenge when these industries are also
competing with us and you know
hiring with uh with much more
competitive compensation packages just
to clarify you're saying you have 14
authorized billets of which only eight
as of Friday will be occupied
correct yep
yep
yeah
so um those are the um
that's the uh the impact on the audit
division which I I know folks who are
interested in hearing us talk about how
would the department absorb moving from
Water's Edge to worldwide so that's my
take on it as the audit director at Keen
I don't know if you want to add anything
further
not not at this point no
so then I unless there are questions on
that we could move into some of the
substantive oh please I do have a
question sure and maybe others
um
so recruiting challenges are inherent
already even if the law doesn't change
totally yes uh resource requirements are
going to increase but what about the
specific qualifications or background of
a adequate candidate does that change
that's a great become more challenging
yeah that's a great question potentially
yes so
what one of the
we try to be flexible these are all
unclassified positions these folks exist
outside of the Personnel rules and
outside of the collective bargaining
agreement and the Union uh that goes a
long way and to help make us more
competitive and allow us to conduct the
work that we do but to your point
directly
yeah we we are going to have to as I
said we're gonna have to find a way to
increase our breadth of knowledge
particularly with respect to languages
and these these other frankly exotic
accounting and currency methodologies uh
that we will need to somehow onboard
that expertise either through direct
hiring or the utilization of service
providers which as you all know better
than me brings its own challenges and
from my perspective
causes me some concerns with respect to
confidentiality respecting the
confidentiality of the taxpayers
information and protecting the taxpayer
which
they're entitled to under the law and
that we have to ensure that we're
safeguarding their information
representative Ellery
yes you had mentioned an exchange rate
and just having a passing it sure it
seems to me that if you're doing an
audit that's over a period of time and
yet an exchange rate is over a period of
hours correct minutes yeah correct so
how do you determine what a dollar is
worth it any given time that that's a
great question and we would need to
bring that expertise on board
um you know presumably that would be
that would have to be hashed out under
audit between the taxpayer and and our
Auditors so they're going to have their
own they're going to have to hire their
own experts if they don't already have
that expertise somewhere so they'll get
that expertise onboarded we'll have our
own people and we'll have to Hash it out
to figure out what would be acceptable
to both sides and and it might be the
case that neither side agrees with the
other and that would just be just yet
another issue to litigate if it goes to
in the in the litigation
I think the phraseology in the
legislature is a lawyer's employment
bill
um but that's right the the other
question I have is you talked about
language problems and translations or
transliterations yep
even English to English could be
difficult sure yep yep
um absolutely
um
but as I said this would
um if we're going to enforce this and if
certainly if
folks are expecting this legislation to
perform a revenue raising function there
has to be a robust audit enforcement
mechanism here and and that's going to
require
um my Auditors to to know what they're
seeing from Source documentation so
they're going to have to read this stuff
directly they're gonna have to be able
to talk with someone to be able to gauge
if this accountant or if this return
preparer is a credible person or not if
what what their gut says
I thank you and the only reason I
brought that I was reading some history
last night and this is near the timeline
the Gloucester regiment was decimated in
Korea and the commander asked for help
by saying he was a sticky situation he
was under the command of an American he
said oh it's just a sticky situation who
cares he was being
beat up yeah and the Americans said oh
no big deal yeah yeah absolutely that I
mean that's a that's a great point they
the language challenges and the the
failure for some of these Concepts to be
able to translate easily it is going to
be something we'll all have to wrestle
with
so while we're on audit other questions
thank you yeah
uh since we're in the digital age yes
not like I am most of the time in the
pencil age
um
these subsidiaries that are located here
couldn't they
in nearly all cases provide the
necessary information to satisfy
the audit information that you need here
in the state versus I realize you like
to travel to London okay uh
wouldn't that be when
the dra set up some kind of rules
adopting requiring the maintenance and
availability for audit of taxpayer
information relevant to this wouldn't it
yes that's a great question so combined
here yeah that's a great question so the
the ease of transmitting information has
definitely got a lot easier
um that's a great point and and you're
right we utilize that right now with
secure file transfer applications and
encrypted emails and all of that so
that's an actual it's an excellent point
and we we use that already and that
would have to be
um part of any uh audit in a worldwide
environment
um but there's there's something to be
said and and I'm a big advocate of field
work it until uh Lindsay someday gets
gets tired of me and fires me which is
probably tomorrow but I'll always
advocate for field work because
um I just think
as important as the digital tools are
and yeah we can get volumes of
information on a
through a file transfer in us in a
second but you don't know what you don't
know if you don't go and see their
operations with your own eyes someone I
think was Carl Friedman from cost
mentioned uh former commissioner Stan
Arnold and um
Stan actually uh I worked with Stan in
his subsequent life at in private
practice
um and he had a great anecdote that I
I've stolen from him and I keep alive
because I love it um but uh the the
image I like to picture or the image I
like people the picture is um from the
original Indiana Jones where they kept
the the Ark of the Covenant in the in
the warehouse at the end I think it was
the CIA or whomever
um they they've got their top men with
the with the Ark of the Covenant in this
massive warehouse and it's buried in the
back so Stan as some of you know started
as a field auditor
um and he got sent out to
um
audit here uh Water's Edge audit but
they're um it was I won't say which
country just to fully protect the
identity of this taxpayer here
um but it was uh
uh foreign parented company and so he
he's auditing them and they've got him
in the Ark of the Covenant warehouse and
they think they're really sticking it to
him because you know oh yeah you can
have all our documents we're not going
to make them available to you though you
have to come to them and we're going to
put you here and long story short what
they didn't know was that Stan actually
spoke their native language he spoke the
the parent company's language and so he
had no problem rifling through their
stuff and he very quickly found a lot of
damaging information in there so there
there's no uh you just don't know what
you don't know until you actually get
out there see their operations with your
own eyes and we're just going to need to
do that just to see what passes muster
if we just get a bunch of information
from a file transfer that as a practical
matter That's How we'll get most of the
stuff that we probably end up using but
until you get out there you know in
China or I'll I'll shut up thank you
thank you
I just want to add something to that as
well uh even here currently uh in the
you for local US audits uh Water's Edge
audits there are some situations where
the taxpayer says no we're not going to
be transmitting those documents um
uh online or in a CD or anything like
that if you want to see those documents
you have to come to our office so those
situations have occurred before
um and they have their own privacy
um policies and um so we just have to uh
adhere to that
I must follow up on that you mean to
tell me the private in the company can
tell the New Hampshire dra that they
cannot
have that information transmitted if the
rules and legislation is set down that
way so
what the what happens under audit is we
will ask a taxpayer to provide this
information for us and
um week to your point we can escalate
the tactics that we use as necessary we
try not to do that just to preserve the
work and relationship between it's
whether you're a mom-and-pop pizza shop
or the biggest multinational in the
world audit is not fun you don't want to
see keen and Fred show up to your your
doorstep we're nice enough guys but it's
not going to be pleasant for anybody so
um if they resist but say look we're not
going to send you this stuff but you can
come and see it we'll we'll accept that
and we'll we'll go to their location and
we'll see where the documents are
particularly if the records are old and
haven't been digitized if they don't to
your point we do have tactics that can
force we can subpoena them we can force
depositions it can get it can get nasty
so there are tools that we have but we
we like to keep the processes collegial
as possible for as long as possible
before we resort
and isn't it also true that in a field
audit where you have access directly to
Source documents you can make quick
checks random searches etc etc look for
red flags which is completely different
than the kind of fishing Expedition
you'd have to go through to have them
disclose exhaustively everything they've
got that's a that's a really good point
it actually becomes a way of limiting
the scope yes that's a that's a really
good point I was just having this
conversation with actually the auditor
who's retiring and you know the value of
a narrowly tailored request to a
taxpayer as opposed to just requesting
every single thing they have which for a
pizza shop fine but for you know a
multinational we're talking trillions of
pages here that's not you know how can
we be efficient with everybody's time
here okay if if you don't have any
objection and I'm fine with this I
understand that Dan bucks who's still
connected with us on online sure has a
question narrowly focused on the audit
topic
yes
if I could I I guess I have a question
that is after a comment
um and I I must say
I have a very high regard for the New
Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration and I have a special
place in my park for water those who
have to do very difficult work in some
of the most difficult work in in Tax
Administration
um but I I
have always been somewhat puzzled by the
assumption that worldwide unitary
requires any extensive international
travel
and I and I'm I'm not I'm not clear as
to why that is the case
uh when the states practice worldwide
unitary in the 70s and 80s it was at
least for the states that I'm most
acquainted with the smaller States and
and we and we have a uh in that sense
um we're very much like New Hampshire it
was not necessary to travel uh to
foreign lands to acquire the records
uh the the corporations that had a a
connection with the state such that they
had Nexus with the state
uh are operating in the United States
and they have international accounting
firms with offices in the United States
that handle their tax filings
and the records are were typically
available
uh and I must say that auditing
continues today
in the case of worldwide returns that
are voluntarily filed and for a long
time after for example the state of
Montana
uh went to a Watersedge election the
vast majority of taxpayers continued to
find a file worldwide returns for 15 to
20 years it was only in more recent
years when profit shifting became more
popular that corporations increasingly
have chosen to file Water's Edge
but in in my tenure as deputy director
for from 1981 late 1981 to early 1988
and again in the eight years from 2005
to 2013 and during my tenure with the
Molly State Tax Commission for 17 years
where we audited for States for
worldwide returns again even after
Water's Edge there was a substantial
delay in companies switching to Water's
Edge
we never had to send our Auditors uh uh
overseas to conduct these audits we
could always secure the information
the only audit that I recall that we had
to send someone to London for that was
the only trip that was during my tenure
in 2003 to to to I mean from 2005 to
2013 in Montana the only trip that was
taken was to London uh for to look at
the board of directors records to
establish a unitary relationship under a
Water's Edge return
so far under a Water's Edge return you
you may have a circumstance that would
arise or you have some international
travel but that's very rare but this was
one rare instance where we had to look
at board of directors minutes that were
in
um in London and that was for a Water's
Edge filing not for a worldwide filing
so I am puzzled by this because that was
not that that that's was not necessary
to do an adequate worldwide return it
was not necessary to travel overseas to
do so with any kind of regularity I
would guarantee you those trips would be
very noticeable if you were traveling
overseas from Montana there were a few
trips into Canada next door but that's
like going to the next state when you're
in Montana New Hampshire too um
with the Canadians and three provinces
but that was generally for small
businesses in Canada that were doing
business in the United States and that's
not really what we're talking about here
so I I'm puzzled by that that judgment
and I've I've heard that before and I
would be glad to talk with the
Department about the requirements and
also to break put them in touch with
with actual Auditors from the from that
have done worldwide audits before and
had a very high professional level
um and uh people who who've done this so
I hate to I say this make these comments
with some uh trepidation or or regret to
having to do that because I have such a
high regard for any tax auditor at the
state level who does corporate auditing
and I uh and and I have a great deal and
respect for the the Department of
Revenue Administration in New Hampshire
but I guess we just respectively have a
different perspective on this matter
okay so thank you I think that's helpful
to have a counter sure you skeptical
view absolutely you don't have to I
don't think there was actually a
question to answer but it's food for
thought and there may be a value in some
further communication directly happy to
talk with Dan regardless of what you all
recommend to the legislature regardless
of what very good okay thank you Mr
bucks
all right uh yes representative Hillary
I've got two things one
you haven't done a global um or combined
reporting
activity but you do do guilty ones right
yeah so
um is it I mean I think Carl frieden
from cost did a nice job of taking us
through how New Hampshire taxes
um what folks have been calling oh go
ahead go ahead yeah I I understand that
what I'm asking for is from your from
your point of view
how would you do an audit on a guilty uh
claim
so we have a question and I'm not
talking about any specific taxpayer yep
uh but I do I think it would benefit the
the commission if we were to see uh uh
cost analysis of doing that as to your
practice and yes and procedure for that
so is that something that the chair
um so yeah uh we audit guilty right now
already
um and it's
relatively inexpensive to do because
it's part of our existing audit program
because as folks have done a really nice
job explaining already
we dovetail with the federal returns so
we pick up the Federal amounts and what
we're largely
um confirming at our level is just that
they have properly reported it on the
New Hampshire return they've not you
know inadvertently taken the
Massachusetts 95 deduction or they've
not omitted it completely from the
return we're making sure that it's there
we're making sure that um they took the
50 deduction if to your question is how
would we
um audit the substance of the guilty
calculation yeah it's and I think as
maybe someone mentioned already
um
the the thing about guilty is it's not
re it's not really an income class I
mean we call it guilty income but it's
not like some other types of federal
Source income where there's something
you can kind of grab onto it's you know
royalties or it's the payment of a
foreign dividend it's just once income
of a controlled foreign corporation
exceeds a certain threshold that's
defined by the Internal Revenue code
that amount is guilty so it's it's
pretty easy to audit
terrible terrible acronym
um but that's the point I was trying to
get at is that uh your your analysis of
guilty is based upon existing required
uh performance by the taxpayer yes as
opposed to
um something new that is not required
yes you got it and the only reason I I
mention that is because in a prior life
and they required an on-site examination
of all sorts of stuff uh I ours in yep
in Registries of Deeds looking up
property ownership and stuff yep just to
make sure and even currently
bankruptcy courts do the same thing yes
so I I just I'm trying to understand
where one is something that's already
there and the other one isn't yeah and
now we're talking about something else
that so
would it be I don't even know if they
can do it but
or if it would be an extra charge or
something but
could you outline as to how
an audit of
a combined reporting activity would take
place
from your point of view and combine it
with Mr bucks uh
information as to how you
how would you do it how would it be done
and so if I could if I can try to
clarify are you suggesting that perhaps
they would create an outline of the
process they might follow
yes thank you for putting words in my
mouth could you do that yeah at a very
high level we can talk about process
right we can talk about audit tactics no
yes we can talk about the steps you
um okay do we have other questions on
the audit
you have more force and feel free to go
I'm sorry I'm taking notes Here I
apologize
um well let's can you repeat that
question
I I believe you had more uh uh substance
you wanted to go through beyond the
audit question yes to the extent itself
I just want you to be able to resume
yeah yep to the extent it's helpful for
folks we can talk
um a bit about that and maybe just to
get
um
maybe it's appropriate just to really
quickly go through and say at a very
high level
um just maybe to bring it all together
because a lot of folks have talked about
um how we taxed in the past what the
current system looks like and what we
would potentially be moving towards so
maybe it's just really helpful to at a
very high level just to bring it all
back together and I was going to talk
more about this but again
Mr frieden from cost
took the wind out of my sales and said a
lot of this already
um so I'm not gonna get super granular
in the interest of time and be
respectful for everybody but um just
really quickly to summarize so the the
business profits tax was adopted in 1970
and we taxed on a separate company basis
as folks have talked about there was no
combined reporting
um and it's my understanding and if we
had Peter Garr still here
um uh he might remember otherwise but my
understanding is that we have
consistently
included foreign dividends in the tax
base since
um we were
requiring separate company filing
then as folks went through in a lot of
detail I'm not going to beat a dead
horse here New Hampshire moved to
um worldwide combined filing in 1981 as
Peter Garr explained there was
inconsistent application of it at the
time due to Department policy as as he
um said it was the commissioner's policy
I I wasn't there but it is it is true
that the department was not requiring
worldwide combination of foreign
parented companies and as Mr Garr and
others have said it was because of the
perceived litigation risk essentially I
think the determination was we don't
want to have a bunch of income or a
bunch of tax paid in that we'll just
have to refund out if this litigation
goes south so there was whatever the
reason whether that's true or not there
was a department policy not to enforce
it inconsistent application and then in
1986 we uh we moved to the New Hampshire
moved to Water's Edge combined reporting
which as folks have said we've been
there ever since eventually moving from
um three Factor apportionment to to just
sales not super relevant for what we're
talking about today
and then as other folks have mentioned
we do include
um
income in the tax base that folks are
considering foreign Source income this
is all income that either right now or
at least in the past has been treated as
income includable in the domestic base
for federal income tax purposes so this
is consistent with traditional income
tax Concepts as folks said foreign
dividends and the simplest way to it's
pretty I think it's a pretty simple
concept when you break it all down when
you've got a company here domestically
somewhere in the United States
and they receive a dividend from one of
their subsidiaries anywhere else in the
country that comes into the tax base and
we tax it it does get and again that
that has been the case in my belief
since the enactment of the business
profits tax it does get preferential
apportionment so it gets better
apportionment those foreign dividends
get taxpayer favorable apportionment
compared to any other source of income
they essentially get to use the
apportionment factors of the dividend
payer they get to use the factors of
that foreign affiliate that's paying the
dividend to
um essentially put those factors into
the denominator of the apportionment
fraction so you got the the amount that
was paid you have to apportion it by a
fraction you multiply it by a fraction
the denominator gets bigger so the the
resulting apportionment is smaller
because it takes into consideration
those foreign attributes when we're
apportioning that so it gets favorable
apportionment
um and as far as how why New Hampshire
still does this as opposed to not
again we don't take any positions on
what's what you folks should be doing or
not the the rationale that you all faced
when the
um United States at the federal level
was uh or had just passed the tax cuts
and jobs act in 2018
when the the federal income uh the
federal Internal Revenue code was
reformed the there was a decision for
New Hampshire to make
do we want to conform to what Folks at
the time called this deemed repatriation
in other words and I I forget if it was
uh Carl or whomever Professor
hellerstein but um
the at the federal level the uh Congress
the IRS have retreated from the uh
worldwide base to the territorial base
and as part of that
um as
Carl said they would no longer be taxing
foreign dividends the idea being to
incentivize it to incentivize those
companies to bring the cash back to
America but to uh reduce the bleeding
there would be a one-timed deemed
repatriation event where
um like the Congress and the IRS are
going to say okay sure we know you're
not actually paying a foreign dividend
we know that cash is not it's not moving
out of Ireland or the Caymans or
wherever it is China it's still there
but we're going to treat that cash as
having moved here and we're going to tax
it this one time
so New Hampshire was faced with a policy
decision there do we want to conform to
that and glom on to that big pot of
money or do we want to keep getting our
steady kind of annuity every year of a
little bit of foreign dividends every
year like we've always got one of the
other and I think and I cannot speak for
all of you this was a legislative
decision I think the the rationale was
that from a budget perspective it's
harder to manage the general fund with a
one-time enormous you know cash payment
as opposed to a steady much much much
smaller annuity over time and so I think
it was just perceived to be a steady
Revenue Source over time so that's the
reason why New Hampshire did it
differently there it's not that we're uh
we sort of made up this this concept
that doesn't exist we just kept kept
what we had because we we foregoed we
went without the deemed repatriation and
just said we'll get it all as it comes
back slowly
and then as folks have already talked
about we get subpart F we get we get
guilty so I'm not gonna you did a much
better job summarizing summarizing it
than I can and in the interest of time
I'm not going to say any more about that
so I just thought I would briefly
mention all of that and probably the
only other thing that's worth getting at
um worth mentioning
because uh there has been so much talk
about
um
profit shifting and abuses and all of
that I guess the only other thing I
would put in front of folks is we the
dra in particular but New Hampshire
generally and through the arm of the dra
through through us as your agents
um we do have a few other tools that we
can use to combat abuses we have these
theories called substance over form we
have this Theory called economic
substance where the the substance of
what's going on is gonna is gonna
actually govern what what uh matters
um although the burden is against us in
those situations so normally the
taxpayer has Bears the burden under
audit if the department wants to assert
these theories we have the burden to to
prove that no it's in fact the this is
the substance of what's Happening not
the form so that's the only other thing
I think I would put in front of folks
that I didn't hear mentioned
um and then there are a few other
Equitable apportionment theories if we
believe that um the taxpayers uh
statutorily allowed apportionment
somehow doesn't fairly and appropriately
reflect their activity here in New
Hampshire we can change it to be
completely outside of what the statutes
require but again we bear the burden to
show that whatever we've come up with is
the appropriate methodology and you can
bet they're gonna
they're going to dispute that and and
sue us because you know we're going
completely outside of the statute and we
bear the burden there so just some
okay very good guest representative
Valerie
the question I've been asking regarding
pre and post
situation
the percentage of the uh taxable Revenue
received by the state from business
taxes 1981 to 1986 versus after they
change that took place in 86. is that
something that
Dre can come up with is it available or
I I don't think so yeah Keen would know
better than me so just I was in
kindergarten but I'll pass this over to
um regarding that I'm not really sure if
we do have records that go so far back
and even so
um
whether were there any calculations that
was prepared because there are two ways
of getting that information one is if
you have the raw data back in 86 and
after and then we'll we will calculate
uh
fiscal analysis on that the other uh
approach is it calculations calculations
were already done back then and we would
just pick up that uh that information
and and disclose that so um I personally
don't know the answer but I can
definitely look back to see if we have
any kind of uh information in our
archives or something like that we would
very much appreciate you investigating
whether there is information that can be
found
uh
okay
yes
I I know I've asked before but there's
no way really to comp the the premise is
that if we if New Hampshire moved to
worldwide reporting that the um the
transfer stuff the the income would come
back in theory though we don't know the
numbers because we have the guilty
income that you don't have enough
information to actually even quantify or
speculate how those numbers might come
out
uh now we try to calculate that
um in
one of the few reasons is because guilty
is part of the is part of the federal
return and it's flowing through into the
um to the New Hampshire return we don't
pass out data that's on the federal
return specifically on on our system so
we just pick up the the flow through
that's directly from line 28 right into
the federal return to the New Hampshire
return
um we might be able to somehow back into
that number but our system currently do
not have that um that mapped out at this
point and if we were to do that that
would that would not be like a next day
turnaround kind of thing we may not the
data the returns that have already been
submitted we won't be able to get that
data we'll have to be a going forward
basis
and presumably that would require some
changes to how our system works
so
um
I think he did a very effective job at
running through some of what the audit
challenges might be
if if we stipulate for the moments
you've
done an audit and you've made an
assessment
um and the taxpayers challenging your
conclusion
what if any particularly unusual hurdles
are you likely to find in the
enforcement action or in the potential
for litigation or do you think it's just
business as usual and no different
that's that's a great question I uh I
think the short answer is
we do expect
that to be relatively business as usual
um
presumably if
taxpayers have
very little in the way of people and
property here
um some some of our more aggressive
incentives for getting compliance won't
work we can't lean them up for example
if they don't have a lot here
um so there could be some enforcement
challenges there
uh I think our our expectation is for
most folks it would be relatively
similar
very good well thank you very much dra
um thank you to everybody who's
participated today I see that uh Mr
posefsky is still monitored this we have
uh all the way back to uh Mr Opel and
comrades you've stayed with us
um
and I don't see if Professor hillerstein
is still there but but Mr frieden
Miss Beeson thank you very much this has
been a marathon I have to say that uh
when we had our organization meeting in
August we thought we would do this over
two sessions I think it's been
wonderfully efficient so as long as
we've got the stamina this is a good way
to do to do it
um if I can just take a couple of
minutes
I want to make sure that everybody uh
knows we have two more meetings of the
commission that have been properly
noticed and are on the house calendar at
10 A.M on Monday October 2nd
and then again 10 a.m on October 17th
um it's hard to forecast exactly how
things will flow but uh what I'm
envisioning is that when we meet next
Monday uh the members of the commission
will Air everything that we've heard get
everything onto the table uh ask each
other questions determine whether
there's information that we need to run
down and how we're going to get it who
we're going to look to
Akeem of course will be part of that
discussion as a member and Mr Cool broth
I would strongly encourage you to be
present in the event of questions that
might arise during that also I was asked
earlier and we agreed we're going to
arrange to live stream
so again the audience for this
discussion is is varied and includes
people who aren't even in New Hampshire
anybody who participated today can
therefore monitor the discussion and see
whether we've mangled the point you've
made
um and and I would also say that of
course representative Schamberg's bill
hb121 has been retained in the ways and
memes committee and it's part of the
plan for the ways and means to
deliberate on that before our reporting
deadline of November 17th so I'm very
hopeful
that we know what the issues are and
more or less what direction we're going
by the time we finish on October 2nd
it's possible that we'll be far enough
along that we actually work on some
drafts of the report uh and might have
that in front of us on October 17th but
in any event I would expect that on
October 17th we would nail down the
direction and scope
of the commit the commission's report
and I would just add that we don't yet
know whether we'll have a unified Voice
or a divided voice but our process
allows for a majority and a Minority
Report and I'm hoping that we're going
to be able to get those together a week
or two in advance of our November 1st
deadline so that the Ways and Means
Committee can do something with our
report
thank you for the remarkable level of
cooperation all around
yourself